Er läuft nicht wieder.
Doch jetzt, jetzt gehts wieder.
Jetzt kann man es einstellen.
Bug bei 48 FPS.
Also Leute F5.
Jetzt kann man es einstellen.
Das liegt an 48 FPS.
Das ging die ganze Zeit.
Jetzt bugged twitch anscheinend gerade rum.
Also jetzt kann man es einstellen.
Jetzt kann man es einstellen.
Das liegt an 48 FPS.
Das ging die ganze Zeit.
Jetzt bugged twitch anscheinend gerade rum.
Geil.
Ok Leute.
Dann würd ich sagen legen wir mal los.
Ich geh jetzt nochmal schnell aufs Klo.
Ich mach aber das Game schonmal an.
Weil
Die Intro Musik ist schon wieder grandios.
Von dem Spiel.
Ich hab echt und scheiß Leute ich hab übelst Angst vor dem Game.
Also ich übertreib jetzt nicht.
Das Game
Das ist so mitreißend.
Das ich
Ich war fertig mit den Nerven als ich das
das erste mal gespielt hab. Ich war komplett durch.
Und das jetzt noch mit Zuschauern dabei.
Das ist ein bisschen schäbt das Fenster.
Oh der Soundtrack.
Der Soundtrack ist so toll.
Musik
Ich muss mal kurz das Fenster einstellen.
Das bugged ein bisschen.
Musik
Wir haben es gleich.
Aber das Soundtrack ist wirklich grandios.
An dem Soundtrack hat übrigens
die Sonnenblume aus Plants vs. Zombies
mitgeschrieben.
Und ich mein das ernst.
Könnt ihr mal gucken wer
an den beiden Soundtracks beteiligt war.
Musik
4 zu 3 in 2k18
Lull
Musik
Crycam
Ok Leute
Ich bin mal ganz kurz auf dem Klo. Ich bin sofort wieder da.
Musik
Könnte bitte einer von den Mods
schauen ob Kategorie
also sprich ob Spielkategorie
und Sprache auf Deutsch steht und sowas
ob das alles passt.
Weil wir haben ja gestern bei Twitch gesehen, dass es nicht immer so gut
funktioniert.
Musik
Lautstärke ok Jungs.
Und Mädels. Natürlich.
Musik
Wir respektieren ja Frauen.
Ok. Oh man.
Musik
Ich hab echt Schiss vor den Game. Auf gehts.
So die Vorschau gucken ob das alles passt.
Also der Anfang
ist ein bisschen gemächlich.
Da wird das ein bisschen als
Indoor. Ich hab es ja schon mal gespielt.
Der Anfang ist ein bisschen gemächlich aber
man muss aufpassen.
Weil viele Sachen die man so sieht
nebenbei
ergeben später Sinn.
Nicht das was unbedingt
braucht ums zu checken.
Die Story an sich versteht man auch so.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding und das ist wirklich eine super Geschichte.
Also ich finde das ist
jetzt mal ohne zu übertreiben.
Das ist das bestgeschriebenste
Spiel was ich in den letzten 10 Jahren
gespielt hab. Auf gehts.
Musik
Und es ist ein
RPG Maker Spiel. Dementsprechend
sieht es doch aus. Allerdings
mit komplett von Hand erstellter
Kraft also von Sprites.
Musik
Echt gut.
Oh zum Glück, ich habe gerade noch kurz überlegt, habe ich es auf Deutsch gestellt?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber zum Glück, ey, ey, ey, MonkaS.
Ähm, ich bin mir übrigens noch, was muss ich jetzt nochmal erzählen, bevor wir anfangen,
weil das Spiel hat relativ viel Text, also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich alles vorlese,
ja, also sagen wir so, die Hauptdialoge lese ich vor, allerdings, wenn ich jetzt mit irgendeinem
NPC labere oder so, keine Ahnung, ob ich den vorlese.
Also, da sind die zwei, Doktor Rosaline, wo bist du mit deinen Gedanken, Nile?
Entschuldige vielmals, ich bin, oh, das ist übel schwierig für mich, ich habe überhaupt
keine Let's Play Erfahrung, großartig, der Cringe ist real, Alter, entschuldige vielmals,
dass ich hellenhaft versucht habe, dem plötzlich auftauchenden Eichhörnchen auszuweichen.
Das ist der übelste Schwätzer, der Typ, du hast es trotzdem überfahren.
Verstelle die Stimme, please, ich kann das nicht, ich kann das nicht, ich kann euch hier
auf den übelst krassen Let's Play stelzer wackeln.
Oh, du hast es überfahren und bist gegen den Baum geknallt, naja, nicht so schlimm, der
Wagen gehört der Agentur.
Was, du Witze, der Chef wird uns umbringen.
Hm, wir sagen einfach, ich hätte einen Hundenwelpen gerettet.
Er mag doch kleine Hunde, oder?
Mag er, sieht man im zweiten Teil, fällt mir gerade auf.
Es gibt übrigens schon einen zweiten Teil von dem Game, nennt sich Finding Paradise.
Er ist eher ein Katzen-Typ.
Ne, er mag Hunde, erinnere ich mich noch dran.
Warum muss immer alles so kompliziert sein?
Na gut, wir haben so einen Lieblings-Feldknoll gerettet.
So, Krise abgewendet.
Gut, das kann sich alles so in den Bericht schreiben.
Lass uns die Ausrüstung aus dem Wagen holen und losgehen.
Die Steuerung ist äußerst simpel.
Point und ein Klick.
Ausrüstung.
Yeah.
Ab, das müssen wir, lass uns losgehen.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich das erste Mal in Deutsch gespielt habe.
Weiß ich gar nicht mehr.
Gucken wir uns mal das Eichhörnchen nochmal an.
Ausweichen, das Auto nicht zu Schrott fahren.
Das ist ein bisschen viel verlangt.
Übrigens, Fun-Fact, im zweiten Teil fährt sie Auto am Anfang.
Hey, warte mal, was ist mit dem Auto?
Ich wollte mir sichergehen, dass du es nicht vergisst.
Wie du immer an mich denkst, vor allem, Range von diesem Türschließer.
Gigi, der Spoiler.
Es gibt generell ein paar Referenzen auf den ersten Teil im zweiten.
Wobei der zweite Teil, es ist nicht wirklich ein zweiter Teil.
Also es ist komplett neu, halt die zwei Erze sind die gleichen.
Wer hat da einen Felsbrocken hingelegt?
Vielleicht ist das ihr Sicherheitssystem.
Oh Gott, die Übersetzung.
Guck hier nochmal, unsere Zeiten sind zu kostbar für solche Blödsinn.
Versuchen wir ihn auf den Weg zu rollen.
Ast, let's go.
Moment.
Und wir machen einfach Feierabend und geben diesem Ding nicht schuld.
Nein, easy.
Auf drei.
Das hast du doch auch gesehen.
Was war das?
Kein Felsbrocken, so viel steht fest.
Naja, wir müssen sowieso weiter.
Wir können später nochmal darüber nachdenken.
Ja genau, Punkt Punkt Punkt.
Das hat er echt schön gemacht, ich meine für das, dass es ein RPG Maker Game ist, der
Leuchtturm.
Ja, ich kann mich dran erinnern.
Oh Gott, das wird schlimm, das wird schlimm.
Für das, dass es ein RPG Maker Game ist, haben sie sich wirklich verdammt viel Mühe
gegeben.
Hello?
Hör rein, es mattered nicht.
Sie sind da, ok, ich muss jetzt, ich muss jetzt Girlstimme machen, aber das kann ich
nicht.
Die ganzen krassen Let's Player können das, die können für jeden Charakter eine unterschiedliche
Stimme machen, ich kann das nicht.
Ich hab's nicht so mit Let's Play normalerweise, ihr wisst ja, ich hab zwei Let's Plays geschafft
über drei Jahre oder so, moin Scary Lucky, kein schlechter Ort um in Rente zu gehen,
was?
Da geht noch was, Nachtschichten, liebst du oder hast du sie?
Du kennst die Antwort du verdammte Nachteule, wir werden wahrscheinlich wieder eine Nacht
durchmachen müssen, weißt du, ist mir klar.
Und ich bezweifle, dass sie Kaffee haben, ah sie haben Kaffee, halt die Klappe, alter
Lan.
Was?
Und das wäre es, Rauschen mit unseren Ohren, sanft umspielen, Herr Typ erzählt ein Blödsinn,
aber davon krieg ich nix mit, wenn du so viel laberst, so auf geht's, rein.
Vergiss nicht die Ausrüstung, da geb ich ihm recht, für das werden sie viel zu schlecht
bezahlt.
Doktor Watts und Doktor Rosalie nehme ich an, danke, dass sie so kurzfristig herkamen.
Kein Problem, ich bin selbst nicht so gut darin, Tote vorherzusagen, was?
Hab ich mich da grad verlesen?
Sind sie die Tochter des Patienten?
Oh nein, ich bin nur die Pflegerin.
Die deutsche Übersetzung ist soweit ich weiß von Fans beigesteuert, ich glaub das ist nichts
offizielles.
Das sind meine Kinder, Sarah und Tommy, ich habe nicht gerade einen 8 Stunden Job, deshalb
erlaubt uns Johnny hier zu wohnen, ich nehme an dieser Johnny ist unser Mann, Johnny?
Hören Sie, wenn wir es hier mit einem Kind zu tun haben, dann sind wir nicht die richtigen
für Sie, nein nein er möchte nur lieber so genannt werden, er ist oben, sein Arzt ist
gerade bei ihm, kommen Sie bitte mit, also dann, schnappt ihr den Koffer, los geht's,
wenn mein Rücken eines Tages schlapp macht, verklage ich dich auf Schadensalatze, Anzeige
ist raus.
Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel, dass es nicht viel Sinn macht hier am Anfang rumzulaufen
und zu gucken, da ist noch nicht viel, okay ab nach oben bevor ich dieses Ding noch fallen
lasse, bis jetzt hat man noch keine Ahnung, was die beiden hier eigentlich machen, ich
hoffe, ich bin mir nämlich nicht mehr sicher, wie gut hast du das Game erklärt, nach oben,
jo, aber nachdem es der erste Teil ist, glaube ich war das gut, ich habe es komplett gecheckt,
okay sie sind weg, wer zuerst da erst darf die Melodie spielen, der Soundtrack ist so
toll, okay, jetzt ist Absicht, dass
das Sound ein bisschen leiser ist, weil es von unten kommt, für ihr Alter sind diese
Kinder ziemlich gut, ey du bist diejenige, die hier ständig erzählt, dass wir keine
Zeit haben, go go go, wobei ich rein zufällig derjenige bin, der das Gewicht eines kleinen
Maturiten durch die Gegend schleppen darf, jaja, auf gehts, ich erinnere mich wieder
an das Game, es hat mich jules fertig gemacht, ich weiß nicht, wo ich das Spiel gejotzt habe,
das ist Johnny, und das ist der Doktor, der übrigens auch in Finding Paradise vorkommt,
wollen sie aufbauen, erstmal umsehen, wollen wir absetzen, oder wollen wir uns umsehen,
wollen wir direkt loslegen, oder wollen wir erstmal ein bisschen im Haus rumgucken, ich
glaube da gab es nicht viel, ich setze erst, erstmal umsehen, ich will nämlich noch mal
gucken, was hier drinnen war, nix, ok, dann legen wir gleich los, erstmal noch mal mit
Doktor reden, er ist nicht mehr ansprechbar, aber wie es aussieht tut er sein bestes um
bei uns zu bleiben, hallo Ghost QQ, schwer zu sagen, wie viel Zeit Ihnen bleibt, aber
ich würde mich beeilen, Maschine absetzen, jawoll, ja doch, man kriegt am Anfang erklärt,
was die beiden eigentlich machen und vorhaben, ich muss mal kurz schnell checken, ob der
Sound, die Lautstärke so passt, aber ich denke, ne, ja, die Spiele Lautstärke ist gut, oder,
sind Sie sicher, dass eine normale Steckdose für Ihre Zwecke ausreicht, keine Sorge, wir
sind die Fachleute, doch ist es angenehm, ok, sieh mal, Mist, Strom aus, reine Routine,
ich teste, ob ihr aufpasst, wie macht er sich, nicht so gut, wenn Sie mich fragen, er hat
noch ein oder zwei Tage, das ist reichlich Zeit, ja genau, jetzt kriegt man es ein bisschen
erklärt, sie beide können ihm also jeden Wunsch erfüllen, wir können es zumindest
versuchen, bis jetzt haben wir es immer geschafft, denn wir sind einfach der Wahnsinn, er findet
sich halt einfach geil, also, wie lautet der Wunsch, der Mond, der Mond, der Mond, der Mond,
der ist nur lauert,
er möchte jetzt zur Mond bliegen, wir alten Knacker werden auch immer abgedreht, so ist
Wir alten Knacker werden auch immer abgedreht, oder was?
Also, ist das möglich?
Kommt drauf an.
Das Wort, das du suchst, heißt ja.
Warum erzählen sie uns nicht ein wenig über unsere Kunden hier?
Tja, ich weiß eigentlich nicht sehr viel.
Johnny ist ein seltsamer Mann.
In den zwei Jahren, die ich hier gearbeitet habe, hat er kaum gesprochen.
Er hat sein Leben lang als Handwerker gearbeitet und seine Frau ist vor zwei Jahren gestorben.
Mehr weiß ich nicht.
Hilf mir doch mal, ich hätte mehr erfahren, wenn ich seine verdammte...
Was, wenn ich sein verdammter Zeitungsjunge wäre?
Mach einfach deine Arbeit.
Nun ja, ich denke, wenn sie sich im Haus umsehen, können sie noch einiges über ihn erfahren.
Johnny hätte sicher nichts dagegen.
Er hat sie beide ja schließlich beauftragt.
Gut, dann machen wir das.
Also, wer von uns beiden spielt Detektiv?
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal bin ich mit Dr. Watts losgelaufen.
Jetzt nenne ich ja Dr. Rosen.
Wie gesagt, am Anfang ist es ein bisschen gemächlich, aber man muss sich ein paar Sachen merken.
Danke für das Angebot.
Aber ich bin voll damit ausgelastet, einen Backenabdruck auf diesem Stuhl zu hinterlassen.
Das könnte ich auch gut weitermachen.
Tommy und Sarah können sich herumführen.
Sie sind wahrscheinlich unten am Klavier.
Gehen wir mal gucken, Leute, ich muss schon wieder aufs Klo.
Warten Sie, kommen Sie nur einmal kurz her.
Ich habe hier etwas für Sie.
Hier, nehmen Sie das.
Kabelloser Kontrollmonitor.
Damit wissen Sie jederzeit, wie es Johnny geht.
Danke, ich wollte Sie gerade danach fragen.
Ach genau, jetzt sieht man das hier oben.
Nicht, dass es wirklich für das Game relevant wäre.
Wir speichern mal.
Hast du die Drehentrösen am Darmausgang?
Dann noch ist da nichts passiert.
Noch ist da nichts passiert.
Twitch versorgen, das stimmt.
So, jetzt wenn hier gerade Musik läuft, ich muss noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
So, wieder am Start.
Leute, ich habe mal eine Frage an euch.
Und zwar, soll ich noch eine Ankündigung posten für den Stream?
Also sprich Twitter oder vielleicht auf diese YouTube-Community-Geschichte?
Oder wollt ihr lieber im kleinen Kreis bleiben?
Quasi die Leute, die Twitch followen und hier über Twitch reinkommen?
Was ist euch lieber? So bleiben oder noch ein paar Leute dazu?
So, gehen wir mal zu Sarah und Tommy.
Sarah, was wollen Sie? Für mich das Haus.
Yo.
Bis für eine kleine Runde dem Stimmen.
Jede, ich verdiene überhaupt nichts hier dran.
GhostQQ, gar nichts.
Für mich das Haus.
Sarah und Tommy, richtig?
Eure Mutter meint, ihr könnt mich einmal durchs Haus führen.
Okay, vielleicht machen wir das.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Okay, es sind alle für im kleinen Kreis.
Da lassen wir das auf der Post keine Ankündigung.
Vielleicht später auf Twitter, mal gucken.
Ich glaube, wir brauchen einfach ein bisschen Überzeugung, das ist alles.
Oder was meinst du, Tommy?
Oh, ich weiß, die Kinder gingen mir voll auf den Sack beim ersten Mal durchspielen.
Was möchtet ihr denn?
Wir wollen eine Trillion Dollar.
Easy Clamp.
Oder die Zuckerstange, die Mama vor uns versteckt.
Ja, oder die.
What?
Das ist eine riesengroße Zuckerstange oben in dem Regalfach, an das wir nicht rankommen.
Sie liegt in der Küche.
Mama hat sie dort vor uns versteckt, bis wir unsere Ausaufgaben gemacht haben.
Holen sie sie für uns und wir machen mit ihnen eine Tour durchs Haus.
Wie sieht es aus?
Also ich bin ja ganz ehrlich, verlasse den Mist und komm mit.
Aber guck mal, ob das funktioniert.
Wirklich, zehn Stück, das ist easy, funktioniert.
Oder zwölf?
Nicht mehr als fünf.
Die haben sehr viele Kalorien.
Das wird mich jetzt weniger interessieren.
Immer noch besser als eine.
Auf geht's.
Ja, dann führt mich mal rum.
Okay, wo fangen wir an?
Dieser seltsame Raum im Keller.
Ich mag den seltsamen Raum nicht.
Was meint ihr mit seltsamer Raum?
Sie werden schon sehen.
Er ist gruselig.
Wir brauchen aber die Schlüssel.
Der alte Mann hat sie in einem Buch im Arbeitszimmer versteckt.
Okay, wo ist das Arbeitszimmer?
Das ist das Bad.
Was haben wir hier?
Nichts, nichts.
Licht, na gut, das brauchen wir jetzt nicht wirklich.
Im Keller können wir nicht.
Moment.
Er hatte nicht gerade gesagt, ich soll ins Arbeitszimmer und die Schlüssel holen.
Das ist der Keller, hier spielen wir immer verstecken.
Schalten Sie das Licht an, damit wir nicht stolpern.
Tour ist verschlossen.
Okay, wir brauchen den Schlüssel.
Ich habe mich gerade spontan dazu entschlossen, ich lese nicht jedes Dialogfenster vor.
Sondern nur die Haupt, nur die wichtigen.
So, wir können hier unten nichts machen, wir müssen jetzt erstmal den Schlüssel holen.
Die Tür ist abgeschlossen.
Ist das hier das richtige Zimmer?
Okay, wir müssen jetzt, wir müssen das mit dem Schlüssel besorgen.
Wo geht es hier lang?
Ich kann mich da nicht mal so richtig dran erinnern.
Das ist der Bücheraum.
Der Schlüssel für den Salzeraum ist im dicksten Punkt des oberen Regals.
Na, wie praktisch, dass der Raum genau daneben dran ist.
Nein, das lesen wir jetzt nicht.
Im dicksten Buch, das ist doch das dickste Buch.
Zimmer Schlüssel, jawoll.
Weiter geht's.
Jetzt gehen wir in den gruseligen Raum im Keller.
Worum geht es in dem Game?
Also ja, Point and Click Adventure ist das neu.
Ne, das Game ist von 2015. Also es geht darum, dass Johnny, der oben im Bett liegt und ungefähr nur noch 1-2 Tage zu leben hat, einen Wunsch hat, er möchte auf den Mond.
Und die beiden hier, also aktuell sieht man hier nur Dr. Rosaline, der andere sitzt oben, sind von einer Firma, die eine Maschine besitzen, mit dem man quasi Johnnys Gehirn umprogrammieren kann, dass er denkt, er war auf dem Mond.
Und sich so seinen letzten Wunsch erfüllen kann, obwohl es in echt nicht passiert ist.
Allerdings müssen sie dazu rauskriegen, was in Johnnys Vergangenheit so passiert ist, um das Ganze neu programmieren zu können.
So.
Die Tür wurde aufgeschlossen.
Das ist ja wie in einer Höhle.
Wir nehmen das mal mit.
Ein Hase aus Papier gefaltet. Die sind wichtig nachher, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Die Hasen kommen noch öfters vor.
Haben sie es gesehen?
Was wisst ihr zwar über die ganzen Papierhasen?
Der alte Mann wollte nicht, dass jemand reingeht, also haben wir es ihm nie gesagt.
Es gibt sogar noch mehr davon.
Wo?
Im verlassenen Leuchtturm, der ist direkt an der Klippe.
Wollen wir hingehen? Ich habe die Schlüssel.
Dahin sollte ich natürlich auch nicht gehen, oder?
Lull.
Erinnert mich daran, euch zwei niemals in Liles Wohnung mitzunehmen.
Also wollen wir zum Leuchtturm.
Ist ganz schön kalt draußen, aber zum Leuchtturm gehen.
Zum Leuchtturm gehen.
Oder hier bleiben wir auf die Maschine warten.
Leute, was wollen wir machen?
Gehen oder warten?
Chat-Interaktion in 2K18, Lull.
Seit wann läuft das Stream?
Halbe Stunde?
Warten zum Leuchtturm?
Ja warten.
Campen.
Der Sebaro ist Mott.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das Sebaro ist Mott, das zählt dann mehr als...
Jetzt schreiben wir alle warten.
Warten? Okay, warten wir.
Wenn Johnny für die Hasen verantwortlich ist, dann werde ich in seiner Erinnerung vermutlich sowieso davon erfahren.
Wwpd, ich habe gerade gefragt im Chat, ob die Leute lieber kleine Runde haben wollen oder mit Ankündigung und es waren alle für kleine Runde.
Also ab nach oben, mal sehen, ob Nile mit dem Konfigurieren der Maschine fertig ist.
Fear River.
Was ist denn das für ein Lied? Es hat nur 2 Noten, die sich ständig wiederholen.
Fear River von Johnny H. Wilds.
Du hast noch nicht viel, nee du hast wirklich nicht viel verpasst.
Nee, nee, wir haben noch gar nicht richtig angefangen.
Und auch so wirklich erklärt, was die 2 hier machen, wurde auch noch nicht komplett abschließen. Du hast noch gar nichts verpasst eigentlich.
Sag mal, warum kommst du nicht noch ein bisschen später?
Ist nicht so, als ob der Kunde wegsterben könnte oder so.
Ich muss noch was erledigen.
Ich muss auch was erledigen, nehme ich unseren Job.
Jetzt komm mal von deinem hohen Ross, ich bin einmal zu spät und ziehe dich gleich daran hoch.
Sag mir wenigstens, dass wir startklar sind.
Natürlich sind wir das, ich verstehe mein Handwerk.
Wie geil er sich findet.
Der Helm ist auf der Couch, hopp hopp.
Ach hier ist eine Couch, wo ist hier eine Couch?
Guck mal, was die Angehörigen sagen, wobei die Pflegerin.
Übrigens, entschuldigen Sie meine Neugier.
Wie funktioniert das? Schreiben Sie ihm einfach, ah das ist gut.
Okay, das ist gut zur Erklärung, dass man eigentlich versteht, was hier passiert.
Wie funktioniert das? Schreiben Sie ihm einfach ein neues Leben, so wie man einen Roman schreibt, erklären.
Nein, man kann neue Erinnerungen nicht einfach aus dem Licht erschaffen.
Und wie macht man das?
Nicht wir, das meiste erledigt die Maschine.
Natürlich, wir werden nicht gut genug bezahlt, um uns selbst die Hände schmutzig zu machen.
Kurz gefasst, unser Job ist es so tief wie möglich in seine frühesten Erinnerungen vorzudrängen.
Dort angekommen werden wir dann sein registriertes Verlangen nach einem Flug zum Mond
auf die Rekonstruktion seiner Umgebung und seines selbst in diesem früheren Zustand übertragen.
Und mit der Hilfe eines Wikis allgemeiner und persönlicher Daten simuliert die Maschine dann eine Wiederholung.
Nur wird ihn diesmal die Motivation aus seinem registrierten Verlangen sein ganzes Leben lang begleiten.
Also hängt alles davon ab, dass er sich seinen Wunsch selbst erfüllt.
Einfach weil er das Verlangen danach hat.
Wie soll das gehen?
Wir streben noch alle nach irgendwas im Leben, aber kaum jemand erreicht sein Ziel.
Nun, in der realen Welt sind Wünsche und Ambitionen im ständigen Fluss, die entstehen und vergehen.
Jetzt ist ja ja Philosophie hier Vorlesung, oder wie?
Die Leidenschaft führt die Menschen auf ihren Weg, aber dann kommt ihnen das erste Feuer abhanden und sie werden träge.
Oh ja, das kenne ich.
Ich wäre auch träge.
Stellen Sie sich vor, diese erste brennende Leidenschaft wäre immer bei Ihnen, ihr ganzes Leben lang, ohne nachzulassen.
Es mag nicht zu scheinen, aber das hat eine gewaltige Kraft.
Wo wir davon sprechen, keine Kraft der Welt wird einem Totenmann helfen können.
Ich fange also besser an.
Oh, natürlich.
Okay, auf geht's.
Also für alle, die neu dabei sind, mal ganz kurz zusammengefasst.
Aber wir sehen es jetzt ja auch.
Das ist Johnny, der hier im Bett liegt und wir sind Dr. Rosaline und Dr. Niall Watts.
Wie heißt Rosaline eigentlich? Eva heißt sie, genau.
Und sie sind hier, um Johnny seinen letzten Wunsch zu erfüllen.
Allerdings nicht wirklich und das ist das, was die gerade erklären, was auch gerade dieser Dialog da erklären sollte.
Sie haben eine Maschine dabei, die quasi Johnnys Hirn umprogrammieren kann, dass er eben denkt, er hat sich seinen letzten Wunsch erfüllt, ohne dass es in der echten Welt passiert ist.
Und jetzt geht es eigentlich erst richtig los.
Bereit oder nicht, wir starten durch.
Oh, das Spiel war so traurig. Ich habe echt Schiss, dass ich jetzt gleich Übels rumheulen muss im Stream.
Das sollte die letzte erreichbare Erinnerung sein.
Hier oben sieht man übrigens, wie weit wir in Johnnys Leben sind. Also aktuell sind wir noch ziemlich zu dem Zeit, kurz bevor er gestorben ist.
Äh, kurz an das letzte, woran ich mich erinnern kann.
Er ist ja noch nicht gestorben, sonst könnten wir das Ganze hier nicht machen. Vergesst einfach, was ich erzähle. Blödsinn.
Das sollte die letzte erreichbare Erinnerung sein.
Deaktiviere die Sprache für alle außer Johnny. Schnappen wir ihn uns.
Aber jetzt kriegt man es ja sogar nochmal erklärt. Die Position in der Zeitleiste lässt sich jederzeit mit dem Auszeigen oben im Bildschirm anzeigen.
Also sprich, wie weit wir in den Erinnerungen sind. Aktuell sind wir noch nicht so weit in der Vergangenheit.
Und das Schöne ist, dass man hier eben schneller läuft, als in der echten Welt hier in dem Spiel.
Wo ist denn Johnny?
Und man sieht hier auch, in den Erinnerungen ist halt nicht alles ausgebaut. Also sprich an die Sachen, wo er sich nicht mehr erinnern kann, sieht man halt nichts mehr.
Aber Hauptsache, wir können die Lichter noch an- und ausschalten.
Wo steckt Johnny?
Nee, hier geht es nicht mehr weiter.
Johnny ist am Leuchtturm. Garantiert ist Johnny am Leuchtturm.
Johnny?
John. Jetzt ist es John.
Was für eine schöne Überraschung. Wir haben hier seltenen Besuch.
Also für alle, die jetzt dazu kommen, das ist die Erinnerung von Johnny. Dementsprechend ist hier vieles nicht so wirklich wie in echt.
Mein Name ist Dr. Eva Rosalin und das ist Dr. von Meddartnich.
Dr. von Matterhorn. Dr. Lorenzo von Matterhorn.
Dr. Neelworz.
Ist Ihnen der Name Siegmund, Agency of Life Generation geläufig?
Oh, also sind Sie beiden von der Agentur.
Das trifft sich gut. Ich habe gerade überlegt, Sie anzurufen.
Ja, Johnny, das hast du auch.
Lily, bring uns etwas Tee.
Lily?
Nun, um genau zu sein, haben Sie uns bereits angerufen.
Wir sind hier, um unseren Vertrag aus der nahen Zukunft zu erfüllen.
Vorsicht, wenn Sie von der Klippe stürzen, müssen wir diese Erinnerung neu laden. Er ist immer so feinfühlig, ja?
Zeig etwas Respekt.
Das ist seine letzte erreichbare Erinnerung, also brauchen wir seine Hilfe.
Im schlimmsten Fall laden wir sie einfach neu.
Sie...
Sie sind hier, um mich zum Mond zu bringen, oder?
Ja, John.
Mein Leben ist eigentlich ganz gut verlaufen.
Nicht gut genug, wie es aussieht.
Oh, er ist so feinfühlig, Dr. Watts.
Also können Sie das?
Wenn Sie mich zum Mond bringen?
Wir nicht, aber Sie selbst können es vielleicht.
Warum wollen Sie eigentlich dorthin?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Und ohne zu spoilern, Leute, man weiß es eine verdammt lange Zeit in diesem Spiel nicht, warum Johnny eigentlich zum Mond will.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe noch nie so in einem Game geheult, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo man rauskriegt, warum Johnny zum Mond will.
Das Spiel ist wirklich super geschrieben.
So, weiter. Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Sorge, Sie können es uns ruhig sagen. Wir müssen es wissen, damit wir Ihnen helfen können.
Wollen Sie ruhen, das Geld? Es muss doch einen Grund geben, warum Sie zum Mond wollen.
Tut mir leid, aber ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Ich will es einfach.
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich diesen Auftrag hassen werde.
Nun gut, Johnny. Ich erkläre Ihnen, was wir tun werden.
Wir müssen in Ihre Kindheitserinnerungen gelangen. Die liegen weit zurück, zu weit für einen einzelnen Erinnerungssprung.
Deshalb werden wir schrittweise durch Ihre Erinnerungen in die Vergangenheit reisen.
Sie haben uns dafür in naher Zukunft schon Ihr Erlaubnis gegeben, das Beruhigen zu wissen.
Sobald wir einen direkten Zugang zu Ihren Kindheitserinnerungen hergestellt haben, kehren wir hierher zurück.
Dann kommt der Moment, an dem Sie uns helfen müssen, Ihre Kindheit so zu beeinflussen, dass Sie später Astronaut werden.
Oder sich einen Riesenkatapult besorgen.
Klar ist aber, Sie müssen mehr dafür tun, als ich weiß es nicht zu sagen.
Solange Sie mich zum Mond bringen, werde ich tun, was ich kann.
Ok.
Um in die Vergangenheit zu springen, brauchen wir ein Memento.
Ein Gegenstand, der für Sie einen hohen Erinnerungswert hat.
Haben Sie etwas für uns?
Geht der Chat noch?
Ihr seht, das ist einer von diesen Hasen.
Das sollte gehen.
Nun, sollen wir?
Ladies first.
Also, man muss echt mal sagen, für das, dass das ein RPG-Maker-Spiel ist, ne?
Das ist echt gut aus.
Notizmond erhalten.
Wir müssen zuerst das Memento vorbereiten.
Vorbereiten.
Bereiten wir vor.
Jetzt kommen irgendwelche sinnlosen Minigames, die aber mega easy sind.
Was Kugel anklicken, um Elemente zu drehen.
Äh, ja.
Easy clap.
Hochgradig schwieriges Minigame.
Gelechne Sprung kann aktiviert werden.
Ok.
Weiter geht's.
Moment, was ist mit meiner Privatsphäre?
Gute Frage, Johnny.
Die NSA liest nicht.
Wir versuchen sie so wenig wie möglich zu verletzen.
Ähm, Sebaro sehe ich auch so.
Sebaro hat gerade geschrieben, ich glaube, wenn das Game in der CryEngine oder Frostbite wäre, würde es viel an seiner Atmosphäre verlieren.
Ja.
Ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt, das sind Videos und Livestreams, ich kann, ähm, so 2D-Sprites, kann ich viel mehr Emotionen abnehmen als 3D-Models.
Liegt wohl an mir, aber 3D-Models kann ich kaum Emotionen abnehmen.
Auch so in Heavy Rain oder so.
Das war alles jetzt nicht sonderlich emotional, ja.
Ok, aber meistens lässt er sich nicht ganz vermeiden.
Die Privatsphäre.
Zu verletzen.
Von Johnny.
So viele Hasen.
Es wäre nervig gesehen zu werden.
Zufrieden.
Wie lang ist das Spiel?
3-4 Stunden.
Mein Gott, was sollen bloß diese ganzen Hasen?
Der Soundtrack ist echt schön zu dem Game.
Da kriege ich ja eine Gänsehaut.
Wir hätten vorher in seiner Akte nach psychopathischen Veranlagungen schauen sollen.
Was zum...
The fuck?
Hat er mich gehört?
Das ist unmöglich.
Es ist wahrscheinlich nur ein Teil seiner Erinnerung.
Dann bleibe ich bei meiner Argumentation.
Was geht mit Johnny ab?
Wie auch immer, hör auf zu quatschen und finde ein Memento, das uns von hier wegbringt.
Stimmt.
Der Hase hat Farbe, der Rest nicht.
Wir müssen die Erinnerungen untersuchen, um weiter zurück in die Vergangenheit zu kommen.
Das ist aber recht interaktiv.
Meistens gibt es dann irgendwas, wo die Geschichte voranbringt, nicht einfach nur etwas sinnlos anklicken.
Ein alter, gepflickter Rucksack.
Stammt ja aus der Steinzeit, das werden wir gleich herausfinden.
Das Kaisersäugleiter von Hans Christian Andersen.
Johnny steht auf das harte Zeug.
Was die zurzeitige Overwatch League ist nicht so deins, oder?
Was macht denn Johnny hier?
Leere Bilder.
Lass es, wenn wir eben unsere Anwesenheit in jeder Erinnerung neu erklären müssen, dreh ich durch.
Führe mich nicht an Versuchung.
Was habe ich hier übersehen?
Gehen wir mal wieder runter, es geht bestimmt unten weiter.
Regenschirm?
Ah nee, mit dem Regenschirm geht es dann weiter, ok.
Die Uhr läuft, aber man hört kein Ticken.
Ah ok, ich muss mal ein bisschen mehr meiner Maus über alles mögliche drüber machen.
Den habe ich schon untersucht, ne?
Ok, dann habe ich oben irgendwas vergessen anzuschauen.
Die Uhr läuft, aber man hört kein Ticken.
Oh, ein Glas.
Ein Glas eingelegte Oliven.
Was gibt es da ganz wahr zu essen, das sind eingelegte Oliven, genau das.
Ah, Buch.
Ah, die Blumen da unten.
Frische Wildblumen.
Wir haben alles entdeckt.
Dann reißen wir mal weiter in die Vergangenheit von Johnny.
Oh, the Grinch is real.
Dr. Watts.
Nein, ich habe ewig kein StarCraft mehr gespielt.
WTF war das?
Was denn?
Genug davon, ab jetzt übernehme ich das zerschmettern.
Die Minispiele haben mich genervt, als sie das erste Mal durchgespielt haben, das weiß ich noch.
Ich habe dann irgendwann einfach nur sinnlos rumgeklickt.
Weiter.
Ich mag Regen lieber, wenn er durch mich statt auf mich fällt.
Mir macht das so oder so nichts aus.
Scheint so, als würden die Erinnerungssprünge immer nur einen kleinen Zeitraum überbrücken.
Wir müssen ein passendes Memento finden, sonst brauchen wir noch Ewigkeiten.
Ach, genießt doch einfach die Landschaft.
Geht sie irgendwo hin? Nee, geht es nicht weiter.
Guck mal, Johnny hat dieses komische Ding dabei.
Das Plüsschnabel-Tier.
Ich meine, wer hat kein Plüsschnabel-Tier?
Ernsthaft, dieses Tier sollte nicht das Recht haben zu existieren.
Die Welt ist nicht groß genug für zwei von eurer Sorte.
Was macht Johnny hier?
In Gedanken an River E. Wiles.
Sagen wir einfach mal, in Gedanken an River.
Tja, wer ist denn River?
Noch wissen wir es nicht.
Es ist fertig, River.
Wie du, so kann ich auch...
Wie du, so kann auch ich nun jeden Tag auf sie aufpassen.
Was auf das Plüsschnabel-Tier?
Sie wird nicht mehr alleine sein.
Was ist das denn?
Ich werde vielleicht niemals verstehen warum, aber ich habe deinen Wunsch erfüllt.
Ich bin sicher auch an, er ist dir dankbar.
Aber wenn ich fort bin...
Wer wird dann über uns wachen?
All dieses Game, das macht mich fertig.
Jetzt schon, ey.
Wer sind sie?
Mein Name ist Eva, ich komme nur zufällig vorbei.
War sie ihre Frau?
Ja, ihr Name war River.
Ich bin froh, dass sie River nicht übersetzt haben.
Ein außergewöhnlicher Name.
Das hätte nicht passieren müssen.
Hä?
Sie hätte es nicht tun müssen.
Aber...
Sie würden das nicht verstehen.
Ich verstehe es ja selbst nicht mal.
Was hat er denn da stehen?
Und wer ist Anja?
Anja, jemand um den sich John und River sorgen.
Ich muss jetzt nochmal gucken, was das hier ist. Was hat er denn hier stehen?
Ach, das ist der Grabstein.
Oder? Das ist ihr Grabstein. Jetzt erkenne ich das.
Das ist der Grabstein von River.
Wurde auch Zeit, dass du auftauchst.
Ich dachte schon, du wärst von der Klippe gefallen.
Was hast du getrieben?
Den Ausblick genossen, was sonst?
Fortschritte gemacht?
Große Fortschritte, riesig.
Tyrannosaurus schreckt-artig.
Ist das die Musik von dem Game?
Ja.
Das Game hat übrigens einen Soundtrack, den kann man sich kaufen, wenn man den Entwickler unterstützen will.
Ist super Soundtrack.
Ziemlich einsam hier.
Es ist ein Leuchtturm, was erwartest du?
Wie auch immer, wir sehen uns auf der anderen Seite. Die Barriere musst du diesmal selbst durchbrechen. Viel Spaß.
Eine kaputte Leuchtturmlampe.
Was?
Also wir sind noch nicht sonderlich weit in die Vergangenheit gekommen.
Hat Max schon geweint.
Ja und darum geht's denn, ne?
WBPD, darum geht's ja.
Was zeigt die Mindestbewegung?
Diese Minigames sind mir sowas von wurscht.
Hat er schon gesagt, warum er zum Mond will?
Nein, hat er nicht.
Und ich kann ja auch sagen, das wird bestimmt noch ein, zwei Stunden dauern, bis wir wissen, warum Johnny wirklich zum Mond will.
Da seh Baro hier wieder mit absoluten Insider-Informationen am Start.
Gehen wir weiter in die Vergangenheit.
River lebt!
Und Johnny ist jünger.
Also sind wir ganze Stücke in die Vergangenheit weitergekommen.
John, das kommt ganz gut hin.
Und schon wieder jede Menge Hasen am Start.
Wenn deine Operation bezahlt ist, wird noch genug übrig sein, also mach dir keine Sorgen.
Notlüge.
Ach ja, ich erinnere mich gerade wieder.
Man muss genauer darauf achten, wie River redet.
Weil, ich hatte am Anfang, als ich das letzte Mal gespielt habe, weiß ich noch, habe ich erstmal nicht verstanden, was das Problem, also was River für ein Problem hat.
Oder was mit River los ist, habe ich beim ersten Mal Durchspielen erst nicht wirklich kapiert.
Das heißt, ich kann euch nochmal so einen Tipp geben, guckt mal, wie River reagiert und wie sie so redet.
Dann wird es dann zwischenzeitlich klarer, was mit River los ist.
Man sieht schon, River ist sehr direkt.
Notlüge.
So nennt man das doch, oder nicht?
Äh, nein.
Ich bin sicher, wir können einfach...
Hör auf!
Ich mag es nicht, wenn du lügst.
Ich hab nachgerechnet, ich weiß, wie es aussieht.
Warum willst du mich gegen meinen Willen überzeugen?
Wir brauchen das Geld für deine Behandlung, River.
Ich weiß, dass Anja dir viel bedeutet, aber das hier, das geht zu weit.
Ist Anja dieses Splüschtier?
Ich meine, sie ist nicht einmal...
Weißt du, was mich glücklich macht, Johnny?
Was denn?
Weißt du es?
Frauenlogik.
Nun, ich weiß es.
Ich hoffe, du kannst mir dabei helfen.
River.
Wenn die Papiere für meine Behandlung ankommen, werde ich sie nicht unterzeichnen.
Was du mit unserem Geld machst, kannst du selbst entscheiden.
Ja, wer spoilert, fliegt raus, sag ich euch gleich.
Aber wenn du meinen Wunsch erfüllen möchtest, dann verwende das Geld, um das Haus fertig zu bauen.
Und dann möchte ich, dass du nach ihr siehst, jeden Tag, den du dort lebst.
Besuch sie, sprich mit ihr, tröste sie.
Wie auch immer Anja ist.
Ich will nicht, dass sie allein bleibt.
Und was ist mit dir?
Glücklich.
Ich werde glücklich sein.
Johnny.
Jo.
Ich habe das hier gemacht.
Zeig mir, was es ist.
Ein farbiger Hase.
Good Job.
Hä?
Zeig mir einfach, was es ist.
Es ist ein Hase, wie die anderen auch, die du gemacht hast.
Und weiter.
Naja, er ist aus Papier.
Der Körper ist gelb und der Rest ist blau.
Gut, weiter.
River.
Ich habe ein Lied geschrieben, es ist für dich.
Okay.
Nun möchtest du es hören?
Ja.
Du hättest nicht extra das Piano hochbringen müssen.
Nicht schlecht, Johnny.
Nicht schlecht, das Ding die Treppe hoch zu tragen.
Ich kann dich sehr gut hören, wenn die Tür offen ist.
Es heißt Fuel River.
Warum so klischeehaft?
Das ist nur ein Arbeitstitel.
Wenn man sich jetzt den Sound genau anhört, wird man merken, das ist eine andere Version von dem Lied als am Anfang.
Wer ist diese Anja, von der beide gesprochen haben?
Und was wir auch gesehen haben, ist, dass River sehr direkt ist und kein Blatt vor den Mund nimmt.
Wie ist diese Anja, von der beide gesprochen haben?
Wenn die so wichtig ist, hätten wir sie nicht in seinen späteren Erinnerungen sehen müssen?
Schätze er hat sein Versprechen letztendlich doch nicht gehalten.
Also nach ihr zu gucken.
Es sei denn?
Es sei denn was?
Egal.
Ist auch natürlich Frauenlogik.
Ja, was ist?
Was?
Sag ich dir nicht.
Aber vorher dreimal fragen willst du wissen.
Hey, das ist doch dasselbe Lied, das die Kinder vorhin gespielt haben, oder?
Vermutlich hat das ihn beigebracht.
Ach, weißt du.
Jetzt zieht nur mein terzester Rundspiegel runter.
Ich mach mich auf den Weg.
Ich habe schon meine Memo-Links.
Komm mit, oder willst du noch selber weiter schauen?
Na ja gut, wir können ja hier nirgendwo hin.
Gehen wir mit.
Gehen wir einfach.
Hey, schau mal, was wir hier haben.
Das unfertige Haus, wo wir vorhin drinnen waren.
Ich wette, sie haben die Klippen gesehen und gedacht, es wäre noch nicht gefährlich genug, solange keine Leute drauf wurden.
Johnny.
Diese Appell.
An Leute, die sich Johnny nicht mehr so hundertprozentig erinnert, die sind halt so grisselig.
Und manche sind auch komplett grau.
Ich habe dir eingelegte Oliven mitgebracht, die magst du am liebsten, stimmt's?
Da ist das Glas wieder.
Ich habe von Ulva gehört.
Wird sie wieder gesund?
Ihre Krankheit wurde erst spät festgestellt, glücklicherweise ist sie behandelbar.
Aber die Kosten für die Behandlung.
Wir können uns nicht leisten, das Haus fertig zu bauen, Isabelle.
Wir können kaum die Behandlungskosten bezahlen.
Ich bin froh, dass man ihr helfen kann, aber du kannst dir nicht vorstellen, wie viel dieser Ort ihr bedeutet.
Es wird ihr das Herz brechen.
Ich würde gern helfen, aber Ted und ich können es seit dem Finanzcrash selbst nur knapp über Wasser halten.
Was wirst du tun?
Ich werde ihr sagen, dass wir es schaffen können.
Dass wir uns beides leisten können.
Aber River ist nicht blöd, die hat das schon durchschaut.
Ich möchte nicht, dass sie eine Dummheit begeht und sich nicht behandeln lässt.
Du solltest sie nicht anlügen, Johnny.
Du verstehst nicht, Isabelle.
Wenn sie die Wahrheit herausfände, bin ich mir nicht sicher, was sie wählen würde.
Und?
Wenn sie entscheidet, dass ihr dieser Ort mehr bedeutet als ihr eigenes Leben, dann soll das eben so sein.
Naja.
Da muss ich sagen, da kann ich Isabelle nicht zustimmen.
Was hast du von einem schönen Haus, wenn du selbst stirbst und das Haus, da hast du doch nichts von.
Es geht darum, was sie wirklich will.
Ihr Neurotypischen meint immer, ihr wüsstet, was das Beste für andere ist.
Das mag ich nicht.
Ich hasse es, wenn du mich so nennst.
Glaubst du denn, es geht nur um sie?
Was ist mit mir, Isabelle?
Nach all den Jahren darf ich da nicht auch mal an mich denken.
Ich kann Johnny verstehen.
Johnny will nicht, dass seine Frau stirbt.
Hallo?
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte,
soll ich mein Haus fertig oder sorge ich dafür, dass meine Frau nicht stirbt?
Würde ich sagen, ich würde mich dafür entscheiden, dass meine Frau nicht stirbt.
Ich möchte nicht allein sein, Isabelle.
Ich werde sie nicht sterben lassen.
Das ist anmaßend.
Pech, Pech.
Ja, Johnny, gebe ich dir voll recht.
Was geht dir das an?
Wo willst du hin?
Ich werde ihr etwas von der Klippe mitbringen.
Als wird sie ein wenig trösten.
Was du vorhast, wird davon nicht besser.
Nick wollte, dass ich dir das hier gebe.
Er sagt, das Lied heißt Everything's Alright.
Ich glaube, das ist das Lied, was von der Sonnenblume aus Plants vs. Zombies gesungen wird.
Ja.
Es ist ernsthaft.
Gar nichts ist in Ordnung.
Johnny sagt quasi so innerlich gerade,
Piss dich, Alde.
Ah, mit dem Gurkenglas geht es weiter.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal hier untersuchen, was es hier noch so gibt.
Können wir in das Haus rein?
Haben wir keines Haus?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Ihr seht jetzt nichts.
Gibt es ja nichts mehr drin.
Es ist noch nichts fertig.
Wahrscheinlich sollen wir lieber Johnny hinterher.
Wenn euch der Soundtrack gefällt, könnt ihr ja mal gucken.
Den gibt es einzeln zu kaufen.
Und unterstützt natürlich auch den Entwickler.
Max spielt To the Moon.
Ja, feels Batman.
Noch fehlt es nicht Batman.
Eigentlich fehlt das Spiel nie Batman, sondern eher Cryman.
Ach, ich kann da gar nicht hoch hinlaufen.
Oh Leute, ich muss schon wieder aufs Klo.
What the fuck?
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Ach, ich kann da gar nicht hoch hinlaufen.
Oh.
Wieder da.
Tender for Ben wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Ich kann auch einfach auf meinen 3000 Euro High-End-Klo gehen, so oft ich will.
Easy Clap.
Lösen wir wieder ein super anspruchsvolles, nerviges Minigame.
In die game
Momento aktivieren weil sie nicht oft genug auf dem klo war trinke ich jetzt erst mal was
Ups, da wollte ich jetzt gar nicht hinklicken, jetzt bin ich verwirrt
200 IQ Plays
Einheitrechtsloh so richtig mit Stange zum festhalten und absenken
Automatik, klar kennst du das doch? Hast du das auch gesehen?
Hast du letztens gezeigt im stream eingelegte Oliven erhalten? Momento aktivieren! Jawoll!
Jetzt sind wir ein bisschen weiter in der Vergangenheit
Der Nick sagt also zieh dir die Sache wirklich durch
Die Bauarbeiten starten bereits in wenigen Monaten. Wohlgemerkt, man muss daran denken es geht von hinten
nach vorne also das ist jetzt vor dem anderen war nicht ganz einfach wir mussten ratenzahlung
vereinbaren aber jetzt wo die finanzierung steht wird es schon klappen wie wundervoll
euer eigenes traumhaus und dann noch diese schönen auf was kann ich mal lesen und dann
noch an diesem schönen fleckchen erde ihr habt euch an dem leuchtturm nicht weit von dort das
ja wort gegeben stimmt ja aber das ist es nicht allein river ist hot
ich gebe zu das war nicht dem gelb angemessen ja wir und dieser ort das geht schon ganz lang
zurück ja es ist schön dass wir uns auch mal etwas erfreuliches zu erzählen haben
das spiel ist so sehr erwart mal ab das wird noch viel schlimmer aber man scheint es ja
zu kennen lasst uns anschließen auf euch beide genau auf uns
bin gleich wieder da ich brauche etwas frische luft ich komme ja mein freund ist schon wieder
ganz schön lange her wohl war wer hätte gedacht dass die paar kilometer mal zu einer
solchen hürde werden werden würden diese river immer noch so still was
ach sie ist eigentlich ganz gesprächlich daheim und wenn sie mit isabel zusammen ist
ich denke sie ist einfach nicht gewohnt dass du dabei bist
jetzt bin ich der böse junge was also hast du jetzt diese eine sache erzählt von früher
ja wie hat sie es aufgenommen insgesamt ganz gut aber eine sache gibt es die mir noch zu
schaffen macht seit diesem vorfall basteln sie andauernd diese seltsamen hasen aus papier
origami hasen ja viele jede menge ich habe auch früher mal origami tiere gemacht für
meine tochter als sie noch klein war was ist daran so schlimm ich glaube nicht dass man
das vergleichen kann nick sie macht nichts anderes mehr als diese hasen zu basteln tage
ein tage aus unser haus ist inzwischen voll mit den dingern bis oben hin sagte isabel
nicht dass so etwas bei menschen wie river nichts ungewöhnliches ist bei menschen wie
river schon aber diesmal habe ich ein ungutes gefühl wenn ich sie darauf anspreche antwortet
sie mir nie stattdessen bekommt sie diesen abweisenden blick fast als würde sie irgendwas
von mir wollen und das seltsame ist ich habe das gefühl dass da wirklich etwas ist dass
ich ihr schuldig bin hast du mal isabel gefragt ja sie sagt dass sie mit ihr gesprochen hat
aber auch nichts aus ihr rausgehen konnte tja ich bin sicher nicht der fachmann hier
aber ich kann dir eins sagen ich kenne dich seit der mittelstufe du hattest schon immer
den hang hier um alles einen kopf zu machen du bildest dir da wahrscheinlich etwas ein
machte nicht so viele gedanken wenn jemand so ein rat gibt liegt meistens tatsächlich
was im wagen aber gut ich habe zweifel keine gewissheit wahrscheinlich hast du recht wahrscheinlich
ich habe immer recht johnny dr warts moment mal selbst er hat also johnny hat keine ahnung
was mit diesen hasen los war vergiss die dummen hasen wir haben ganz andere probleme wir sind
hier in einer abgegrenzte erinnerung es gibt keinerlei momentus keine panik wir können
wahrscheinlich eins von ihm selbst bekommen wort sie zu und lerne ich muss nur kurz diesem
wird ein besuch abstatten dem da hallo was darf sein was geht haben sie ein glas eingelegte
oliven für mich das ist ja das was man immer also in der kneipe so 96 ist neu hier sagt
hallo das ist neues feature hallo 96 das kenne ich noch gar nicht ich wusste gar nicht dass
man wenn man das erste mal im chat ist jetzt irgendeine nachricht schreiben kann nice haben
sich ein glas eingelegte oliven für mich gar noch zahlen sie bar oder mit karte check
tut mir leid schext nämlich ja dann schreiben sie es einfach auf mein deckel moment soll
das heißen sie haben kein geld ich werde ich sowas von gesetzen hallo was darf sein
wo spielt das game also wenn ich im land kontinent keine ahnung kein schimmer das
hat das spiel überhaupt keine rolle ich würde mal sagen irgendwo in europa vielleicht so
frankreich oder so keine ahnung tagtisch haben sie ein glas eingelegte oliven für
mich klar doch zahlen sie bar oder mit karte schreiben sie auf meinen deckel heute mache
ich richtig ein drauf oho geht klar der herr hier sind ihre eingelegten oliven ich mache
auch mit eingelegten oliven ein drauf danke kumpel da wird heute jemand eine menge trinkgeld
einstreichen danke der herr ja wenn der wüsste kann sein arsch sein hier acht nörg dich
locker alde was mache ich jetzt mit eingelegten oliven ich setze mich jetzt zu johnny und
red mit ihm über eingelegte oliven na nun sehen meine getrübten augen der etwa ein
gläschen eingelegte oliven so ist es sie müssen auch eine gute oliven zu schätzen
allerdings ich habe mir gerade eben ein frisches glas bestellt was für ein zufall darf ich
natürlich setzen sie sich wir kippen gemeinsam ein gläschen eingelegte oliven ja das klingt
doch nach einem plan effa geschmack simulation aussetzen jetzt ich habe keine lust dafür
wüsste noch was dafür wüsste noch bezahlen tja und so sind wir zu unserem ersten toaster
gekommen haha alles in ordnung ja mich nimmt nur das geschmackserlebnis diese eingelegten
oliven total gefangen einfach wundervoll nicht wahr oh ja man kann sich kaum vorstellen
dass irgendjemand diesen dinger ekelerregend finden könnte lassen sie sich zeit wir haben
ja nur zwei volle gläser also habe ich gesagt hey das ist also habe ich ist das in scope
oder was hier los also habe ich gesagt hey ist das nicht in ordnung und sie haben mir
recht gegeben johnny labert und wissen sie was noch an unserer gesellschaft nicht stimmt
blablabla blablabla blablabla ich habe sogar dabei wieso darf ich mal sehen na gut bitte
sehr das ist das klavierstück und anhalten endlich die wache die oliven die halte die
klappe bist ich alde momento gefunden fangt bloß nicht wieder an macht dir keine sorgen
siehst du alles nach vorschrift
der tür hat teilweise so den übertrieben klinisch dialog das lese ich jetzt nicht
vor ernsthaft ich versuche gerade mich in die situation rein zu versetzen du versaust
die stimmung das war es wert ok machen wir wieder ein ganz tolles minigame übrigens
ich hatte als ich das das erste mal gespielt habe hatte ich keinen bock auf die minigames
da habe ich einfach immer wild rumgeklickt bis sie gelöst waren moment
ich habe alles gelesen ganz bestimmt aktivieren wir sind wir am leuchtturm und sie sind eine
ganze ecke jünger wieder also wir sind wir sind ziemlich schnell gerade das das spiel
ist ja auch nicht so ultra lang das ist eher ist halt einfach interaktive geschichte als
als game heiliges känguru du bist kein australier ja und wir sind hier ungefähr 20 millionen
nanometer über normalnull und stehen auf einem verdammten lampenmast springe einfach
runter das ist ja nicht so als könntest du dich hier verletzen machst du witz das ist
wie bungee jumping ohne seil das ist so ein schwätzer der typ um bleiben geht nicht runter
kommen auch nicht man ich hasse ist wenn was reading skills nur um bleiben geht nicht runter
kommen auch nicht machen wie ich es hasse wenn das passiert ich schwöre dir wenn diese
orte efer what the fuck war ich jetzt haben sie echt schön gemacht hier für ein pg maker
spiel river warum warum hat man sie wohl verlassen ich nehme an sie wurde einfach nicht mehr
gebraucht nicht mehr gebraucht für schiffe meine ich du weißt ja wie das heutzutage ist
mit gps und all dem kram
dieser ort bedeutet mir sehr viel und ich habe nachgedacht im moment läuft doch alles
recht gut für uns und wenn wir sparen ein paar jahre lang dann können wir hier oben
ein haus bauen wir werden uns einschränken müssen aber ich wir könnten sie vom fenster
aus sehen morgens abends wir werden immer in ihrer nähe und wir könnten jederzeit
hierher gehen sie wäre nie mehr allein schon ich könnte jeden tag auf sie aufpassen ja
das werden wir ich gönne es ihr das meinst du nicht ernst du weißt was passieren wird
oder es ist als würde man einem zug bei man klar ist zusehen da hat er recht das ende
ist nicht wichtiger als irgendeiner der moment die zu ihm führen was zählt ist dass die
beiden hier und jetzt glücklich sind lass uns gehen ich kann es an der stelle noch mal
sagen wenn ich mir das hier so angucken ich kann einfach ich sage jetzt mein anfangen
billigen 2d sprites so viel mehr gefühl abnehmen ja und emotionen abnehmen als ich das 3d model
kann ich weiß auch nicht was aber ein problem ist in der richtung aber bei mir ist bei mir
also moment mal sie haben den leuchtturm anja genannt oder nicht ich glaube schon dann
hat diese river auf medizinische versorgung verzichtet wegen einem leuchtturm ist das
nicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben also ich habe in diesem beruf schon merkwürdigeres
erlebt ja ich auch aber ich gewöhne mich einfach nicht daran es kann dir ohnehin egal
sein sie ist schließlich nicht unsere patientin notiz anja erhalten ok anja ist tatsächlich
der leuchtturm und wegen anja wollte sich river nicht operieren lassen sie ist halt
hart drauf aber das schöne ist es ergibt alles wunderbar sinnen in dem game und wir
werden auch gleich noch erfahren warum
ne da müssen wir nicht hinterher hallo fenris blu die musik ist auch wirklich sehr stimmungsvoll
max punch ja ist die soundtrack ist echt gut eins der besten game soundtracks zu game
zu musik ist wirklich super ich glaube wir sollen hier runter
haben wir hier runter auf die straße
ein haas hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen hätte schon nicht zufällig drauf geklickt
neil bitte keine cringe dialoge mehr
vorbereiten
moment ich habe mich aufgepasst fack ich bin überfordert von von mini games
moment wie wie funkt ok ok mal langsam
ich bin verwirrt
ich bin nicht mehr verwirrt 900 IQ plays
advanced brain jetzt schon die aber noch eine ganze ecke jünger oder ja johnny ist jetzt
keine ahnung 40 river steckt river der haase gibt es sonst nichts zum angucken
wo ist river wo ist johnny das ist jetzt definitiv nicht ihr haus das ist jetzt ein altes anderes
haus ein alter flügel
die treppe drauf bekommen keine ahnung aber ich werde das wäre ein klacks für die tadis
für was
das verstehe ich nicht
damit steht fest pianos zu bewegen ist für jener albtraum es würde wahrscheinlich eine
komplette episode lang dauern das dort hinzubekommen was ist tadis die würde ich mir sogar anschauen
dr hu habe ich nicht geguckt deswegen check ich das wahrscheinlich nicht
tadis kurz für redans das wahrscheinlich nicht ok dr hu keine ahnung habe ich habe
ich nie geguckt
kann ich alles verstehen
damit kann man durch raum und seien ach sind das die telefonzellen aus dr hu
das sind die telefonzellen
doch das habe ich mir irgendwo gelesen
jede menge papierhasen wieder john johnny du bist so früh aus dem haus gegangen um zum
friseur zu gehen
der fris meister wusste gar nicht dass er hier mitspielt
was machst du da
hasen river ist immer sehr direkt hast du den hasen gesehen den ich für dich da gelassen
habe
ja
erzählen wir etwas über ihn ok dieses spiel macht river wohl öfters
beschreibe ihn river will
river will johnny mit diesen hasen irgendwas sagen
so wie es für mich aussieht und johnny checkt es nicht weil river fragt ihn jetzt schon
zum zweiten mal jetzt im abstand von ein paar jahren
was er zu diesem hasen sagt und johnny checkt es irgendwie nicht
er war gelb und weiter
ein bisschen pummelig
und
naja es ist eben ein papierhase
ich wüsste nicht was ich sonst über ihn sagen soll
du benimmst dich merkwürdig river river benimmt sich schon die ganze zeit merkwürdig
ist etwas nicht in ordnung
ich weiß nicht wie es dir geht aber ich habe gerade eine art umgekehrtes déjà vu
ich glaube ich weiß was mit ihr los ist aber selbst dafür ist das ziemlich ungewöhnlich
glaubst du sie ist
glaubst du das
jetzt spuckt aus jungs
vielleicht wer weiß
leider ist das spiel schon so alt das heißt einige von euch haben wahrscheinlich sogar
schon gespielt
deswegen frage ich jetzt nicht was meint ihr denn was ist mit river los
und ich mit karsten mit river
weil ich finde wenn man aufgepasst hat das merke ich jetzt immer am zweiten mal spielen
kommt man eigentlich drauf was mit river los ist
zumal dass isabelle früher vorhin auch noch quasi indirekt gesagt hat
vielleicht wer weiß
aber wie du schon sagtest sie ist nicht unsere patientin
lasst uns die dinge zu ende bringen für die wir auch bezahlt werden
also was wir jetzt aktuell über river wissen ist sie ist relativ direkt
sie ist nicht sonderlich einfühlsam und macht komische dinger und versucht johnny irgendwas
mitzuteilen was er nicht versteht aber was für sie relativ
klar ist
und er siehts einfach nicht
ah ok hier gehts weiter
das ist jetzt der tag an dem sie damit anfangen
also hier hasen zu falten
guck mal was johnny dazu zu sagen hat
nichts
ein eimer
viele lange orangefarbene hasch drin
hab ich irgendwo was vergessen anzuklicken
glaub ich hab irgendwo was vergessen
da hab ich oben was vergessen
hier das hab ich vergessen
ein gelber papierhase
oh Gott nicht schon wieder
ah das hätten wir am anfang sehen sollen
haben wir aber nicht
das ist der dicke papierhase von dem sie unten gesprochen haben
wir haben nicht richtig geguckt
wir sind point and click noobs
nein da hab ich nicht drauf geklickt
sagen die noch was sie hat ja
man versteht was mit river los man versteht in dem game prinzipiell alles was passiert
am ende
was ist woran man sieht wie gut das game geschrieben ist
ok nein neil oder wie wenn man nicht ausspricht
keine cringe dialogue bitte
nein diesmal nicht ok weiter
optimale anzahl drei lull drei
max fast richtig
sebaro ich fürchte das kommt noch
aktiviert
ok weiter in die vergangenheit
also dieses komische schnabeltier hat irgendwas damit zu tun
hab ich hab ne donation gekriegt hab ich grad gehört im hintergrund
muss ich mal kurz gucken
schonmal danke für die donation von
candyman gea du bist einfach der geilste boi wo kippt 10 euro 51 danke
ok gucken wir mal weiter wo sind wir jetzt hier gelandet
also dieses komische tier das ist überall dabei
ich weiß ja die hälfte von dem game auch nicht mehr
bloß ein paar schlüssel sachen noch
viele sachen fallen wir jetzt auch zum ersten mal so richtig auf
dass wir nichts vergessen
bei nie gibt es nix einfach einfach laufen und gut ist
sebaro nicht spoilern alles wird sie nicht machen
muss ich dir nicht sagen
so wo sind sie oder wo ist was
hier ist nix wir sind genau falsch gelaufen wir müssen auf die andere seite
also ich muss echt sagen also für ein RPG maker spiel
ist hier wirklich sehr viel liebe reingeflossen
und details
das ist die stelle an der früher das haus stand oder
das haus das niemals hätte sein dürfen allerdings kommt das erste paar jahre später
mal ehrlich was finden die leute an ungewöhnlichen hohen und gefährlichen
plätzen denn so faszinierend
höhenangst stimmt nil hat höhenangst
stimmt fällt mir wieder ein
nein hat oder nie oder nein wie man ja auch hat höhenangst das kommt das kommt in
finding paradise noch öfters mal
mal nebenbei was ist ein rpg melker das ist
spiele spiele engine quasi für halt so 2d games
also quasi so was wie unity plus viel viel viel viel viel viel viel viel viel viel viel
viel viel viel viel viel einfacher und für 2d
wo geht es denn lang
genau hier stand das haus früher
was heißt früher äh später wird das haus hier mal stehen
wisst ihr was leute wir speichern mal das kann nicht schaden
der rucksack
deswegen hast du mich damals angesprochen
ja
wie sieht es jetzt aus
schätze es gehört dazu
es gehört dazu
nicht dass es hier gleich jetzt fsk 18 wird
hör mal das ist lang her
es spielt eigentlich keine rolle mehr aber
idzi isabel meinte ich sollte dir besser die wahrheit sagen
ich hätte unser erstes treffen nicht so vermasseln sollen
so richtig mit augen kontakt hat's riva auch nicht das haben sie echt gut gemacht
was ist das ein hacky sack
kannst du ihn bis zu anja werfen
anja ist wirklich der leuchtturm
keine ahnung soll ich das probieren
würdest du
klar
johnny will riva beeindrucken natürlich will er
riva bist du verrückt geh weg
hoch
ich glaube diese erinnerung ist nicht so weit von der letzten entfernt
was glaubst du besteht da ein zusammenhang
wahrscheinlich
es macht was mit dem rucksack los
memento gefunden
wieso hat sie sich die haare abgeschnitten
ich mag lange haare
das schöne ist dass ich das game wirklich vor drei jahren oder irgendwie so gespielt
habe also sprich ich weiß eigentlich bis auf ein paar sagen gar nichts mehr zu die wichtigen
sachen
ok minigame
minigame skills
easy
clap
schreckt minigame
aktivieren
isabell
die störung wirkt sich bei jedem anders aus john
nur weil wir beide daran leihen sind wir nicht dieselbe person
aber du musst uns doch irgendwie helfen können
anfangs war alles noch ganz in ordnung aber jetzt ist sie nur noch distanzierter als vorher
selbst wenn selbst wenn wir im selben zimmer sind sie ist nie wirklich da
das geht mir langsam an die substanz
ja johnny das kann ich verstehen
was ist schlimmer
als wenn du fragst was stimmt nicht
wenn offensichtlich was nicht stimmt
und da kriegt man als antwort nichts
dann muss man ein bisschen weiter fragen jetzt erzähl doch mal was ist denn los
nein nein ist nichts
ich weiß nicht mehr wie ich das aushalten soll
nun ja ich kann ich für sie sprechen aber viele von uns wollen nicht alleine sein
von uns
eine ganz andere frage ist aber ob man das auch zeigen kann
es könnte der grund sein warum river hasen bastelt
dass sie sich damit schwer tut heißt noch nicht dass sie keine gefühle hat
sie schließlich immer noch da oder
manchmal musst du dir einfach den klauen bewahren dass du ihr wichtig bist
es ist nicht leicht sich das zu sagen jeden tag aufs neue
ich weiß
sag mal warum wirkst du eigentlich so normal isabel
die ist eine grausame abkürzung für isabel
ich meine habt ihr nicht die gleiche sache
nun ja bei mir wurde es festgestellt als ich noch sehr jung war
es ist mühsam aber nicht unmöglich sich dann eine maske sozialer norm systematisch anzueignen
jetzt kommen wir der sache leer was river eigentlich hat
weißt du ich bin ein river ebenso wie ich sie bemitleide
ich bin schauspielerin geworden weil ich mein leben lang eine sein musste
nicht nur auf der bühne sondern auch sonst immer
nein samsung es geht immer nur rückwärts
ich bin so gut darin geworden weil ich keine andere wahl hatte
nur so kann ich normal sein
aber river hat das nie versucht sie blieb einer außenseiterin und hat nie
etwas dagegen getan
ich weiß nicht ob sie es nicht konnte oder nicht wollte ob sie tapfer oder feige war
es gibt tage an denen ich die ganze verstellerei einfach nicht mehr aushalten kann
und dann merke ich es ist zu spät
die isabel die die leute kannten
die isabel die die leute kennen ist nur eine show
um ein wahres ich ist zu einer fremden geworden
ich glaube letztlich beneide ich river
jetzt kommen wir der sache wirklich langsam näher was river hat
ich glaube es wird nie genau ausgesprochen aber man kommt drauf
und wenn ich sage ich es euch nochmal das muss auch versteht
ich habe noch nie eine frau mit solchen problemen getroffen
dann hast du wohl bisher noch keine einzige frau getroffen
also ich denke an der stelle kann ich verraten was river hat
weil man hat es eigentlich schon komplett
man hat es komplett erfahren ja fennrys blue hat es erkannt
also sie hat keine gespaltene persönlichkeit
sie ist autist fennrys blue hat das erkannt
sie hat asperger river
das wird glaube ich nie in dem game wirklich genau so gesagt
aber es ist ziemlich offensichtlich
die welt wäre ein schöner art schöner ort wenn sich die leute gesichter besser merken
würden
sprich leute die erinnerung egal sind sind halt einfach grau
irgendwas neues heute
was liest du da
des kaisers neue kleider
deswegen hat das johnny auch später in seiner wohnung liegen gehabt
ich habe es geliebt als ich klein war
und tust du es noch
natürlich
nur aus anderen gründen
als ich ein kind war stand ich total auf die animoff serie
ja gut johnny war ja auch normales kind
weiß ich deine mutter hat dir ein animofs buch zu unserer hochzeit geschenkt
ja das war ein ganz schön marktwürdiges geschenkt
ich war als kind wohl ziemlich besessen von dieser serie
ich habe als kind muss ich jetzt gerade an der zeit sagen was ich als kind geil fand
war super teenage mutant ninja hero
bestes er ja
totals beste serie
ja und weil wie meister splinter damals schon gesagt hat
manchmal ist rückzug die bessere verteidigung
oder irgendwie so
das fand ich geil damals
warum hast du sie seitdem nicht wieder gelesen
ich habe die bücher gesehen sie verstauben in der garage
näher ich bin herausgewachsen schätze ich
gut johnny ist jetzt auch ungefähr
keine ahnung 35
diesmal vielleicht eher nicht mehr animoff die animoff serie
es sind eben kinderbücher
was ist falsch daran kinderbücher zu lesen
johnny was ist falsch an kinderbücher zu lesen
sie spenden trost
schon möglich
ich werde mir wohl dieses hier kaufen
ich lieb mich und du liebst dich wir lieben uns ganz fürchterlich
grandioser buchtitel
hey river das hier ist gar nicht mal so schmalzig
social heulen was ist das das wirst du gleich noch sehen
und was ist mit davids
der ist mein lieblingscharakter john ähm keine ahnung
worüber redet ihr animoff kennen sie das
ja natürlich kennen die animobs was sonst
ich habe keine ahnung was es ist aber es hört sich an wie irgendwie
sowas wie turtles was ich früher geguckt habe
wirklich mehr oder weniger
wissen sie in welches tier sich david verwandelt
was weiß ich in welches tier sich david verwandelt
in eine a-meise ich hab keine ahnung
wo ist denn das s
ah mehr geht nicht fuck
das klickt nicht richtig
keine sorge ich finde es schon noch heraus
ah in eine cobra verwandelt er sich ok
du hättest doch einfach googeln können ok das spielt nicht so lange in der vergangenheit
cobra in co in eine cobra verwandelt er sich ok das muss man ja ich weiß es in eine
kodra
ha richtig eine kodra
beatport wir spielen to the moon das geht hier ab
ich wünschte wirklich sie hätten noch die alten cover statt diese öden umschläge ist
wirklich cool
so jetzt haben wir alle momentos zusammen jetzt können wir eigentlich
weitermachen
zumindest wissen wir jetzt dass river autist ist
autistin wir respektieren ja frauen
kann man nicht so rumdrehen das ganze
moment man kann nicht so rumdrehen
ich bin schlecht schlecht in diesen komischen puzzle
ja aber spielte als ernsthaft sieht nicht aus wie ein typisches max game man sollte
sich nicht von der optik eines games so sehr darauf festlegen was das für den game ist
nur sind es eines der besten wie nennt man das es ist ja kein spiel in dem sinn quasi
buch in spielform was ich je gespielt habe
aktivieren
visual novels genau ja so was in der richtung
und vor allem eines der spiele mit dem besten saunter überhaupt
so jetzt dürfte johnny so ein paar zwanzig sein würde ich sagen
doch es gehen schon alle ich bin doch gerade erst da
scheinlich beim parties häufiger so zu passieren
ach komm hebt ihr deine kindlichen scherze für heute und für leute ohne selbstbewusstsein
auf
guck mal da ist wieder das olivenglas und das buch
ich sehe le fromage was oh es ist französisch
aber wo ist die maus ne manchmal check ich deine witze nicht
du redest ja immer viel plötzchen aber das ist bisher das highlight des abends
willst du nicht eher sagen dass ich nur kese rede
wo sind wir jetzt irgendwo im wald warum sie stehen im wald so viele leute
mit denen ich nix anfangen kann
wo sind die dann überhaupt alle was machen die hier geht jetzt nicht weiter
ah patrick siehste jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich den witz auch kapiert
ich brauche halt ich bin ich bin ja schon 33 das braucht manchmal einfach ein bisschen
länger weißte
kein big brain
wir kommen echt gut voran in dem game
ich glaube das letzte mal habe ich länger gebraucht
ich habe auch alles angeguckt so jetzt sind sie mal eine ganze ecke jünger
22 würde man sagen kurz nach ihrer hochzeit
hier man kann nicht mit ihnen reden
john fühlt es sich anders an
ich meine jetzt wo wir die ringe tragen
nein
river ist da immer sehr direkt
warum fühlst du dich anders
also eigentlich ja ich denke schon
fühlt es sich an
es ist einfach anders
wahrscheinlich nur die verantwortung
verantwortung
magst du den namen anja
jetzt wissen wir warum der leuchtturm so heißt
möchtest du sie anja nennen
ich verstehe
anja ist ein schöner name für sie
nachdem wir jetzt wissen dass river autist ist ergibt das auch viel mehr sinn warum sie
manchmal so sachen erzählen die vielleicht jetzt erst mal
bisschen merkwürdig klingen
hey komm mal her
sebaros sagt river ist so niedlich ja finde ich auch
das ist keine gute idee ich werde stolpern und fallen
keine sorge folge mir folge einfach mal in schritten
ich glaube du bist mir auf den fuß gedrehten
äh ups komm versuchen wir es noch mal
jetzt ist ihre hochzeit
das tue ich
und möchtest du diesen mann der nun vor dir steht
johnny wiles zu deinem ehemann nehmen
versprichest du ihn zu lieben zu ehren in guten wie in schlechten tagen bis dass er
tot euch heidet
ja
kraft meines amtes erkläre ich euch hiermit zu mann und frau
meine damen und herren vor ihnen stehen mister und missus wiles
die hochzeit ja was dachtest du denn was das wird
ihr habt sie somit hochzeiten das ist alles flüssigkeiten sammeln sich in beiden augen
ich wusste gar nicht dass es sentimental sein kann
oh sag dich augen ich mein mund und da sammeln sich nicht nur flüssigkeiten
sondern auf festes das ist ein reizender gedanken all das wollte
ich schon immer mal wissen
komm lass uns einen weg hier rausfinden all diese glücksähligkeit ist selbst für mich
zu viel
nein ich mag es einfach nicht anderen dabei zuzuschauen wie sie fehler begehen
frau doktor wo bleibt
denn ihr augenblick was wo bleibt ihr der augenblick zählt
so können wir doch irgendwas einsammeln
uns fehlt noch ein
jetzt irgendwas vergessen uns fehlen noch zwei
ach hier unten gehts weiter
ich sollte mal schauen wie es meiner tante geht
alles klar mama sag ihr dass ich mich freue dass sie gekommen ist
mach ich
übrigens mal ein hinweis drauf wenn wenn das mama von johnny ist
ist das mama von johnny dafür ist sie aber ganz schön verschwommen oder
meinen seine mutter erinnert man sich normalerweise
ich bin so stolz auf dich johnny
der nick ist wieder am start
ach so hieß mein großvater ach moment hat hat hat sie ihn grad johnny
oder joey genannt
er ist gestorben bevor ich geboren wurde mama nennt mich manchmal so als spitznam ja sie
hat sie hat joey gesagt
ich erinnere mich wieder was mit joey auf sich hat
nick wie kommt es dass du mir nie davon erzählt hast
weil ich besser finde wenn du mich john nennt
johnny
nicht noch eine von diesen großeltern kindheit großeltern kindheit
wieso was hast du dagegen
ich meine über deinen großvater erzählst du immer eine ganze menge
was stimmt doch gar nicht
ganz wie du meinst
joey erhalten
ja wer ist joey
johnny spitzname nach seinem großvater
ich erinnere mich dass es nicht so einfach war
so habe ich jetzt irgendwo was vergessen
wo gehts denn weiter
heute ist noch irgendwas aufgefallen wo es weitergeht
ah hier unten können wir noch mal gucken
ich bin so stolz auf joey
warum joey
was hab ich denn vergessen
und vor allem wo ist das momento wo es weitergeht hier kann man ja nichts anklicken
ach hier unten gehts weiter
was ist da los
da kann man nichts mehr machen river
ich bin sicher es war keine absicht
komm schon wir kommen zu spät
warte mal ist das ein hase
ach ja weil eben jemand gesagt hat im chat hat das gefühl dass die erinnerungen vorwärts
und rückwärts gehen
also die szenen die gehen immer nur von vorne nach hinten allerdings in so einer szene je
nachdem wo man hingeht
können die ereignisse schon in unterschiedlicher reinfolge sein
also das ist jetzt ja eindeutig vor ihrer hochzeit
weil sie sind ja gerade auf dem weg zur hochzeit
warte mal ist das ein hase
was meinst du ist das der ursprung der ganzen papierhasen
warum sollte sie sich an der sache mit dem überfahrenden tier dermaßen festbeißen
vor allem erst so viele jahre danach
was fragst du mich
du bist hier die frau
davon werde ich erst überzeugt sein wenn du dich traust einen bungee spuck ohne seil
zu machen
tote hase hat es irgendwas damit zu tun
da komme ich ins minigame
so jetzt kommen wir immer mehr in die jugend von johnny
der typ du weißt dass es eine fantastische hochzeit war wenn das momento ein überfahrendes
tier ist
hey vielleicht sah sie das als eine art metapher für die schreckliche ehe
und ein jahre später fing sie an hasen zu falten weil sie sich daran erinnerte wie
sehr ist hier was wie sehr das hier zum himmel steigt
ja nein fantasiert ihr nichts zusammen
oder was weiß ich irgendwas ähnlich wichtig turisches
coole cool story brau
da ist der hase armes ding was das eigentlich heute für was das heute für ein tag mit
den ganzen überfahrenden tieren schau mich nicht so an
es riecht nach bauernhof hier und nach überfahrenden tieren
das ist den geruchssimulator deaktivieren und schleunigst vor dir verschwinden
das ist ein krass animiertes horse da kann bdo einpacken
lass es sein was genau soll ich sein lassen das weißt du genau
ich soll es sein lassen nicht von diesem pferd was nicht auf diesem pferd zu reiten
wie alt bist du fünf zwölf by the way
ok ich werde auf keinen fall auf diesem pferd reiten
auf gehts hör auf zeit zu verschwenden
fuck das ist nicht gut
und mach was steh nicht blut rum verdammt das stand nicht in meiner stellenbeschreibung
was sagt die notiz zu dr.
leih dr.
watts
wo sind wir jetzt hier gelandet auf dem bauernhof ist aber nix
wirklich und die erinnerungen hören hier halt auch auf river
und johnny jetzt würde ich mal sagen so keine ahnung 20 jahre oder so
ich auf das pferd drauf und mit reiten
moment was ist denn jetzt gehts jetzt hier weiter oder nicht
hallo habe ich irgendwas übersehen
ich glaube ich habe irgendwas übersehen oder kann doch nicht sein dass ich so lange
rumlaufen muss
vor allem in diesem in diesem schneckentempo
ja und hier ist die erinnerung fertig
hier ist die straße wieder
ich muss doch auf das pferd drauf oder
also ich kann mich da noch dunkel dran erinnern muss die jetzt pferd reiten
ach guck mal da bewegt sich was da oben ein bisschen verbacktes pferd
musst du hier nicht reiten doch ich muss reiten aber irgendwie check ich nicht was
ich genau machen muss weil aufs pferd klicken ging nicht
hallo ich muss reiten ich weiß dass ich kann mich da noch dran erinnern ich muss hier definitiv
reiten
ist das verbackt ach nee ich muss einfach ein bisschen nach rechts laufen ob das wirklich
eine gute idee ist
hier kommt schon klar sie macht das nicht zum ersten mal
aber sie ist bisher noch nie alleine geritten ich kann das ich bin kein kind
ja ich stand einfach an der falschen seite
worauf warst du komm schon
ey wart auf mich jetzt darf ich da wahrscheinlich drauf
steht praktischerweise noch ein pferd für mich dabei
ich frage mich ob ein alt schon von dem pferd runtergekommen ist
was für ein Spaß
ach zum maiskolben damit tolle übersetzung
was nähertaste zum kalibrieren jetzt ziehen sie aber alle register vom rpg maker
wie muss ich jetzt hinterher reiten einfach rum reiten oder
muss ich in busch reiten
ja was geschafft
wo ist das nächste moment das pferd ich speichere mal wo ist das nächste momento
memento oder wie immer das ding heißt wo gehts weiter
wo ist eigentlich johnny
hier dieses momento wird uns weiterhelfen aber ich setze mich nicht nochmal auf dieses
pferd besorgt die restliche memory links habe ich doch
vorbereiten
habe ich jetzt irgendwas verpasst hier näher ich habe eigentlich alles ich habe alle ich
habe alle links johnny ist auch hier noch am rum reiten wir sind fertig was du hölle
spielst du das weil es ein geiles game ist
ist der beste der am besten geschriebenen stories der letzten paar jahre in dem spiel
das wieder verkackt warte mal ich klicke jetzt einfach sinnlos rum ich habe keinen bock auf
sagen wir habe ich jetzt habe ich jetzt alles hier drinne gefunden ist das absicht dass
ich jetzt vom pferd dieses ding auslösen muss wahrscheinlich aktivieren 200 IQ 900
IQ
sind wir im krankenhaus würde ich sagen die diagnose steht fest fragezeichen dr.
li ja wir sind uns einig was die Ergebnisse angeht
leider und dieses schicksal teilen sie mit vielen menschen die von einer tiefgreifenden
entwicklungsstörung betroffen sind kommt die diagnose spät hätten sie davon schon gewusst
als sie noch klein waren hätte es ihnen vieles ersparen können
haben sie irgendwelche bücher darüber
dieses hier ist von tony and wood er ist eine koryphäe auf diesem gebiet gibt es den typ
wirklich sie können es erstmal ausleihen kostenlos brennen sie uns nur nicht damit
durch danke doch nun sind sie beide ein paar unverheiratet und ohne sonstige rechtliche
bindung ja ich verstehe nun ich könnte sie an einen spezialisierten therapeuten überweisen
wenn sie das möchten gibt es irgendwelche schwierigkeiten in ihrer beziehung
nein ja für river ist das ganz klar johnny sieht das mit sicherheit komplett anders
und wie sehen sie das
nein alles in ordnung wie auch immer sie sollten das buch ebenfalls lesen
der sebaro hat hier wieder den wikipedia artikel rausgekramt tony and wood ist ein britischer
klinischer psychologe er ist auf das asperger syndrom spezialisiert und hat zahlreiche bücher
anderen und andere medien über dieses thema veröffentlicht das bekannteste und zahlreiche
sprachen übersetzte buch ist asperger syndrom der deutsche titel lautet das asperger syndrom
das erfolgreiche praxis handbuch für eltern und therapeuten also sprich das hat der dokter
gerade river gegeben und ich glaube spätestens in diesem moment ist klar dass das spiel uns
sagen will river ist autist es wird ihnen helfen den zustand ihrer partnerin zu verstehen
wpd trollt wieder übelst rum es wird ihnen helfen den zustand ihrer partnerin zu verstehen
lieber nicht wieso nicht also johnny komm jetzt stell dich mal nicht so an nun gut das
ist ihre entscheidung
für die vorläufige behandlung gibt es die sogenannte hypotherapie die könnte ihr helfen
eine ranch nördlich von hier bietet sie an ihr könntet das in die wege leiten
nach deswegen waren die pferde pferde rennen reiten freund ich habe sie doch gesagt dokter
rosalie wusste schon die ganze zeit wollte bloß nicht spoilern kommt mal kriegen wir
auch erzählt was wer tonny tonny tonny linksbums edward ist der autor einer buchreihe über
rivers störung
das kann man nicht aufmachen
entschuldigen sie können sie bitte die urleise stellen sie kann das ticken nicht gut ertragen
ist nicht so schlimm ich halte schon aus
ein problem das mache ich gerne
falls es noch etwas gibt was sie beunruhigt sagen sie mir einfach bescheid ja wenn ärzte
nur so nett werden bzw sprechstunden helfen
hier aktuell würden die eher sagen piste ich alle dann wart woanders
eindrücken vielen praxen dass es die überhaupt nicht mehr juckt
dokter rosalie das erklärt wohl die uren im haus könnt ihr euch noch an anfangen erinnern
da sind wir durch das haus und alle uren haben nicht mehr getickt
komm mal da ist wieder das schnabeltier was hat das mit dem schnabeltier aufsicht ein
plüss schnabeltier ich kann es nicht fassen dass diese scheußlichkeiten so früh in erinnerungen
auftaucht
da hat jemals ein plüssstier wohl sehr sorgsam behandelt und hatte was dire angeht ein ziemlich
miserable geschmack
nicht mehr lange sie werden dich gleich aufrufen
jetzt wissen wir es offiziell auch wenn wir es vorher schon geahnt haben und ich vom ersten
spiel noch im hinterkopf hat river ist hat asperger
was habe ich was vergessen wo habe ich vergessen was einzusammeln
hier eine einfache gelb braune handtasche
so aktivieren
sind wir hier gelandet jetzt sind wir im theater oder sowas
und jetzt schon ziemlich jung
passt nicht passt schau ich weiß ich kann auch nicht glauben dass er für sie diesen
film bezahlt hat nein schau wir sind gesprungen
johnny ist jetzt ziemlich jung jetzt schon was ist johnny 14
der bengel ist allein im kino was für ein versager
du gehst ständig allein ins kino das ist was anderes
niemand ist kompetent genug mein gesprang zu verstehen
aber das mal außen vor wie kann sich jemand diesen müll hier antun
daraus folgt dass der film auf hand an was reading reading skills max und daraus folgt
dass der film auf der handlungsebene wie auch der meta ebene ein völliger reinfall
ist natürlich
komm schon gehen wir was ach ja richtig
gehen wir mal johnny hinterher gucken was da los ist
muss ruhig grammatik ist ja nicht mal ein ganzer satz lasst uns einfach momentos schauen
darmentoilette herrentoilette
was macht denn johnny da
lasst mich raten johnny wartet auf river und river ist nicht gekommen
das sind die dritte person die du entfernt hast
ja ist doch egal können wir immer noch gesetzen
noch mal johnny
doppelt johnny
versetzt worden
du kannst dich gut in alles gleichen einfühlen wie ich sehe
was muss ich denn machen
dr watts ist so ein fast
hier ist nichts
tut mir leid das sagen zu müssen aber ich fürchte wir müssen ihn noch mal ausquetschen
viel erfolg wenigsten sind hier diesmal keine oliven
johnny ist auf jeden fall nicht gut drauf
du warst die ganze zeit da drin
ich habe im foyer auf dich gewartet ich dachte schon du wärst nicht gekommen
warum bist du rausgegangen ich dachte wir wollen den film gemeinsam sehen
was das sollte ich dich fragen
ja für river ist das ganz klar sie sitzen gemeinsam drin und gucken den film man muss
nicht zusammen sitzen um den film zu gucken man kann im gleichen raum sitzen um den film
zu gucken das reicht
in rivers logik ist das vollkommen klar
wie meinst du das
wir haben den film noch zusammen angeschaut und plötzlich bist du rausgegangen
wir haben ihn nicht zusammen angeschaut
ich wusste doch nicht mal dass du da bist
wenn du mich gesehen hast warum bist du nicht zu mir gekommen
was macht das für ein unterschied ich meine wir wollten uns den film zusammen angucken
wir haben uns den selben film im selben raum angeschaut
tja johnny lol was hast du du bist so merkwürdig
möchtest du den film jetzt nicht mehr mit mir zusammen anschauen
klar will ich das komm lass uns rein gehen bevor es vorbei ist
ich habe das gefühl ich sollte jetzt eine clevere bemerkung machen
dein gefühl täuscht dich
hoffentlich wartet in die nächste mitfahrgelegenheit
gehen wir rein
hier dürfen wir nicht rein jetzt dürfen wir nur da rein
zack fertig da ist ja wieder das blühstier
das blühst schnabelt hier das ist das ist erstaunlich oft am start
ich habe vergessen was damit auf sich hat ich bin jetzt genauso gespannt wie
ihr ich habe keine ahnung mehr was damit gewesen ist
nein verdammt kein big brain
ok fast fast big brain
aktivieren
wenn ich ehrlich bin ich glaube dieses schnabeltier wächst mir so langsam ans
herz hauptsächlich aus praktischen gründen aber immerhin
river in der schule
komm schon junge hast du keine eier
doch das schon hör mal vielleicht war das doch keine so tolle idee
ach guck mal da ist nick wieder am start ach gott was soll denn schon passieren
denk doch mal nach das schlimmste was passieren kann ist sie sagt nein
du schlenderst weiter als ob nichts wäre niemand wird jemals etwas erfahren
alle halten dich immer noch für cool
mensch not hot und wenn sie jemand davon erzählt
oder mich anschreit jetzt reiß dich mal zusammen du waschlamm
oder oder wenn sie ja sagt was mache ich dann aber eigentlich nein mein
jetzt mach mal haltlamm wer tut jetzt mach mal haltlamm wer tut denn so was
und wenn sie mir eine enzyklopädie ins gesicht schmeißt
ich hab nicht mal ein helm dabei gott ich bin so dermaßen schlecht vorbereitet
alter keine panik bauchreinbrust raus und hör auf dich wie ein waschlamm aufzuführen
genau sag ihm wo es lang geht
alles wird gut dreh dich einfach um
alles klar alles klar ja die sache mit den grills
hey was tust du
auf gehts johnny komm gib alles
ich bin johnny hallo
mein name ist johnny ich komme zufällig vorbei
hallo kannst du mich hören
ja na klar
wieso hast du da nicht egal
ganz schön cooles schnabeltier hast du
das ist der krasseste anmachspruch den ich je gehört hab johnny
der ist fast so gut wie kannst du schwimmen ich würde dich gerne
nein egal was liest du da
ein buch
über schnabeltiere nein
das finde ich toll über leuchttürme
wenn wir wissen dass sie später mal einen eigenen leuchtturm hat
es gibt noch genau 16 leuchttürme mit fernsehschen linsen zweiter ordnung in unserem land
jawoll ich meine das ist allgemein bekannt oder
das wusste man weiß man
neun von ihnen sind an der kürze und einer war vor seinem umbau ein historischer leuchtturm
mit kerosin lampe
achso darum geht es in deinem buch
sag mal möchtest du vielleicht irgendwann mit mir zusammen ins kino einen film ansehen
ich weiß nicht
schon ok du kannst in ruhe drüber nachdenken kann ich nicht äh warum
kein datum keine uhrzeit ja river ist da halt sehr konkret und direkt
oh naja wie wer es an diesem samstag um 8
ich glaube das ist dem hängt ja jawoll ich nehme an die einzelheiten klemmen dann später
guck mal wie sie sogar hingekriegt haben dass wir ein bisschen schüchtern guckt
ähm ja ich ich gehe mal
schaust du mich so erwartungsvoll an du meinst sicher dass ich jetzt noch einmal ausspreche
wie unglaublich peinlich diese vorstellung war
vergiss es den gefallen werde ich dir nicht tun lass ihn doch er war eben noch ein kind
gerade du solltest ja wissen wie man sich da fühlt
was wie was heißt was soll das heißen halt die klappe wir müssen weiter
halt die klappe ist nicht mein name ein schnabel plüschtier
was zum teufel war das denn man wieso ich hab mich verabredet
das war erbärmlich an deiner stelle wäre ich da einfach reingeplatzt und hätte die
kleine sofort abgecheckt und weggecockt ungefähr so
hey du ausgehen ich du jetzt
das ist einfach schrecklich ich weiß aber es wäre immer noch besser
als das was du gerade durchgezogen hast hat sie dir ein enzyklometin ins gesicht geschmissen
nein halt die klappe man alter piss dich
siehst du ich bin nicht der einzige ich bin nicht der einzige leute immer sagen muss wenn
sie die klappe halten
wie konnte ich mich nur von dir überreden lassen dieses dämliche fach zu gehen
ach komm stell dich nicht an das macht spaß nur weil man malen kann
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie ja keine ahnung
ein bisschen wie die heavy breathing cat falls sie noch jemand kennt
übung macht den meister klar sicher nach diesem schuljahr werde ich nie wieder ein
pinsel in die hand nehmen
fenerys blu ja das sagen wirklich leute ernsthaft
so blöds klingt das ist weil glaubt das nicht aber gibt es
hör auf zu mosern ich bin mir sicher du wirst du wirst lernen das zu mögen
wie dafür gab es kein memory link
leonardo da vinci hat geübt indem er eier malte fester sind wie sehr große eier
klingt logisch
so gesehen werden werdet ihr alle sehr große da vincis
natürlich was sonst
sieh irgendwas niemand
guck mal johnny und river
wirklich niemand
wenn das so ist
river warum gibst du uns nicht die antwort
ich weiß dass du die antwort kennst
wir warten
na schön
erstarr am dritten august 1942 in see
geht zum columbus
1492 in see
von der spanischen stadt palos de la frontera aus
die 1322 gegründet wurde und an ja blablabla
ist gut ist gut ich wollte nur das datum
seht ihr das war jetzt so war das jetzt so schwer
haben alle leute ein so fotografisches gedächtnis
nicht wirklich obwohl ich glaube dass ihr mustergedächtnis
oft sehr ausgeprägt ist
achtung sie kommt zu uns rüber
alt tab alt tab
gucken sie sich brand an oder was in der schule
alt habe halt was ist die notiz zu alt tab moment
lebensretter da ist was dran
da ist was dran
abgeschlossen nur in der mittagspause geöffnet
jetzt denn weiter da
wie wäre es beim nächsten mal solltet ihr flaschen mal besser etwas besser sein
ein auer die können wir für später gebrauchen
ich kann nicht glauben dass die spielfeld markierung in seinem kopf rechteckig sind
das stimmt na gut was ist der jolly hat wahrscheinlich nie wieder basketball gespielt
da schön du hast gewonnen
ja ja
als mittagspause weil da alle hinrennen
ja als mittagspause hallo morbid martin
klar ist sie was besonderes besonders langweilig
ich meine schau sie dir noch mal an
ich weiß gar nicht was die alle haben
wie sie das jetzt allein den ganzen tag mit dieser gruselig deformierten ente als blühstier
das ist keine deformierte ente das ist ein schnabeltier nick
ein was hör auf die tiere auszudecken
nick hat nicht so big brain
wie auch immer sie ist so dermaßen nehmender spur als wäre sie von einem anderen planet
oder so
ich weiß ist das nicht cool
sicher wenn man auf aliens und solches zeug steht dann wahrscheinlich schon
mal im ernst wenn du durchgeknallt sein willst warum hängst du nicht einfach mit den emos
und gothicks rum
naja zum einen will ich mir nicht die haare ruinieren und die tatsache dass wir schon
unsere schubladen für sie haben macht es nicht besser
sie meint ich will einfach kein durchschnittlicher junge in einem ozean durchschnittlicher leute
sein
da sagt johnny was
warum zur hölle sollte es denn deine identität ändern mit ihr zusammen zu sein
ich meine du wärst dann einfach ein typ der mit einem schüchternen mädchen rumhängt
sie ist nicht einfach nur schüchternig
und faszinier ist anders
anders zu sein ist auch nicht immer so toll
weißt du denn überhaupt ob sie wirklich will
weißt du denn überhaupt ob sie das wirklich will anders sein
vielleicht will sie einfach nur dazugehören so wie alle anderen auch
wir wissen mittlerweile das möchte refer ganz bestimmt nicht
und wenn das so ist wäre es nicht hilfreich sie in die andere richtung zu drängen oder
hör mal nick die sache ist die ich weiß was ich brauche
doch john kennt sich aber aus und dieses mädchen hat es
na da ist aber für sein alter schon gut dabei der johnny
also willst du sie weil sie etwas hat aber nicht um ihr selbst willen
philosophisch für die schule das ist eiskalt man
ich hoffe nur du weißt was du tust ich weiß es
ich glaube übrigens du hast unrecht
die menschen sind nicht durchschnittlich jeder ist auf seine art etwas besonderes
das erzählen doch nur irgendwelche oma
guck mal seine tasche die hatte später immer noch
moment mal dieser typ ist so eine art hipster
dass ich an andere menschen dran warnst das ist irgendwie verstörend
ich weiß er littl samsung keine ahnung ob die 13 14 sind also
ich würde mal sagen ja oder vielleicht 16 17
weißt du manchmal möchte ich unsere kunden ein ordentlich kopflos verpassen
so ist die high school so ist die high school jeder ist ein spast
aber er will kommen im club heißt dass sie barus sagt heißt dass das johnny
river nur weil sie nicht wie alle andere 0815 menschen sein will
sieht aktuell so aus aber wie gesagt am ende ergibt das alles wunderbar sind
warte mal darum ging es also bei dem gespräch an der klippe
was an der klippe hat er ihr erzählt warum er sich an sie ran gemacht hat
oder wie war das jetzt vermutlich
dann kriegte sie einen sprung in der schüssel und begann diese unheimlichen hasen zu basteln
stimmt weil er ihr die ewig zurückliegende sache gebeichtet hat
man könnte sich durchaus als nachtragend bezeichnen
übrigens nick nick spoilern hier ich sag's noch mal
falls du das game kennst nein mein gefühl sagt mir dass da noch
mehr ist dann hol schon mal dein hutscher log
komm ich glaube unsere mitfahrgelegenheit lehnt da vorne am tisch
ich brauche noch ein ein momento wo habe ich das vergessen
die lusche ove hi
guck mal ob river vielleicht noch ein momento hat
von den hintergründen mal abgesehen ist es ziemlich erstaunlich dass die beiden tatsächlich
in der high school zusammen kam
wie viele von diesen perchen bleiben zusammen schon länger als ein welche wie viele von
diesen
ich kann nicht mehr lesen wie viele von diesen perchen bleiben heutzutage schon länger als
ein monat zusammen ich weiß nicht wie es bei dir war
mit meinen medels lief damals alles klats
was ist klar so glatt dass sie mir im handumdrehen alle
wieder hinklitten klingt als könnte das stimmen
oh nein jetzt kommt wieder irgendein spruch
oh nein ich wusste es ich wusste es
und cool efer wtf
noch mal man stört niemals jemand in seinem kamehameha
mormon martin sagt man was hast du eigentlich mittlerweile für eine internetleitung ich
habe vdsl 100
wat
vorbereiten weiter geht's
nähern wir uns langsam johnny's kindheit wo wir dann endlich verstehen was eigentlich
mit johnny und river und was da eigentlich los ist
ich klicke jetzt einfach mal ich habe keine ahnung wie man es eigentlich lösen müsste
so
big brain
intuitive hier
intuition big brain
keine ahnung was ich sagen wollte
weiter
hi hast du schon battaglia und battaglia 1944 versucht
noch nicht versucht ich dachte es kommt erst nächste woche oder so
funktioniert bei dir shadowplay
ja
qualität ist übel scheiße du musst die qualität hochstellen in den settings mit wieviel
mbit da aufnimmt
wo sind wir hier jetzt
so mama ich gehe jetzt zur schule
machs gut joey
ich hab das schon mal durchgespielt feels batman ja vor drei jahren oder so
so genau kann ich mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern
ich weiß nur dass die story wirklich herz zerreißend war
mein kleiner junge er wird so schnell erwachsen
auf gehts johnny
mein gott und wenn er ein mädchen wäre würde sie ihn dann auch mit dem namensans
großvaters anspruchs sie nennt ihn ja nicht sie nennt ihn ja joey und nicht
johnny
ich überlese das immer weil ich lese das zu schnell
die mutter sagt ja zu johnny immer joey
das wäre gar nicht mal so schlimm er endet immerhin auf e
joey juey jul g ja genau
wenn du so wenn das so knopfisch klingt wie so heiratest du nicht einfach
eifersüchtig was
euer extrem eifersüchtig
hier gibt es doch ein fußball
den können wir noch nicht
ne uhr die tickt
eine tickende uhr
keiner wer echt auf die nerven geht da hat er recht
was was haben wir hier das kurkenklaas wieder
nicht schon wieder ein klaas eingelegte gurken
du bist ziemlich leicht zu beeindrucken
jetzt ja um
diverse bücher mit unleserlichen titeln
gibt es sonst noch was
ich irgendwas vergesst
habe ich irgendwas übersehen
irgendwas habe ich übersehen
schade dass du keine ps4 hast
sonst könntest du die last guardian spielen max ist von der story her ganz
großes kino ich habe eine ps4
seit release habe ich eine ps4
das wollte ich auch noch mal spielen last guardian
ich habe ego gespielt ich habe shadow of the colossus gespielt was ja so quasi
die zwei
vorgänger wenn man so will waren
so big brain plays wieder
easy
so jetzt mal gucken was in johnny's kindheit so passiert ist
das riecht nach verwesung
wo sind wir
das sieht nicht wie johnny's kindheit aus
btf ist das
was macht das in johnny's gedanken
seine nächste erinnerung
schön aber warum sieht hier was schön aber warum sieht es hier aus wie in la
puta aus
muss ich wohl um eine fehlfunktion der maschine handeln
schon wieder beim letzten update update war die behauptung sie sei nun für
mindestens ein halbes jahr joten sicher
unsere it abteilung besteht aus lauter schwachköpfen
egal halb so schlimm die teenager zeit haben wir abgespeichert
damit könnten wir schon hinkriegen
in ordnung aber ich werde ihm nichts über das hier erzählen
solange wir erfolgreich sind muss er es auch nicht erfahren
ja ich glaube das war es
wir können hier nichts tun
so einfach ist es nicht
bereit für die finalisierung
ladies first
zu schade ich hätte gerne mehr erfahren
auf die erfahrene auch noch mehr die erfahrene alles
zweiter akt
milliarden von leuchttürmen
die fest sitzen am anderen ende des himmels
erstaubt jetzt jetzt geht es langsam los
wo wir so schnell heulen angesagt ist
halten sie mit abstand
sie werden nicht einfach aufwachen aber sie brauchen volle konzentration
jetzt sind wir wieder beim alten johnny
und das ist alles was sich als alternat weiß
tja tut mir leid ich bin wohl keine große hilfe
dann muss das so reichen
no happy meal for you warum
warum kackt die owl richtig rein
dr watz ok jetzt müssen wir nur noch den wunsch mit ihren frühesten
kindheitserinnerungen verbinden
dann legen wir den schall da oben und zack im handloh drehen stehen sie auf
dem mond
ich habe eine frage
wenn sie lily verschwinden lassen können dann bedeutet das dass sie die
welt verändern können
warum tun sie das nicht einfach noch einmal und erfüllen mir meinen wunsch
gleich hier und jetzt
das würde funktionieren
wenn dies ihre wahren erinnerungen wären
was soll das heißen
was ist das hier denn was bin ich
nur eine kopie
eine leihnwand auf der wir arbeiten wenn sie es so wollen
was sie selbst angeht sie sind nur ein algorithmus abgeleitet aus johnny
gut genug für ein abbild von ihm aber längst nicht vollständig wer ist lily
lily ist seine betreuerin seiner
alten pflegerin
alles was wir tun können ist dieses bild auf logische weise schlüssig zu
ergänzen
wie ich einfach die hälfte dialogue nicht richtig vorlesen
wenn wir dann ihren wunsch in ihrer kindheit übertragen
generiert die maschine ein neues leben für sie
eines in dem dieser wunsch in erfüllung geht
dieses ergebnis
schreiben wir dann in das gedächtnis des echten johnny's
sie sehen also selbst wenn sie zufrieden mit uns sind bleiben sie doch
nur ein read-only-programm
ich meine wir können sie resetten so oft wir wollen und
das reicht
ach sei nicht so empfindlich es ist eh nicht real
wenn du das wirklich glaubst warum machst du dir so viel mühe es ihm zu
erklären
ich versuche nur zeit zu sparen
gehen wir
doch doch ist es das was ich wirklich bin
die arbeit einer ganzen nacht
da geht es nicht weiter
du hättest mich wenigstens vorwarten können
dass du noch als kopf herum schwebst
ich kann es nicht leugnen ich gehe einfach gerne mit dem kopf voran
ich würde ja fragen ob das ein scherz sein soll aber ich habe angst vor der
antwort
ziehen wir es durch ich komme mir in dieser gestalt dumm genug vor
alles was wir tun müssen ist seinen wunsch
von der spätesten erinnerung zur frühesten zu transferieren
jetzt kommen
komische schiebe spielchen
ich meine es war das war doch relativ simpel nah
da musste
jaja ich weiß noch wie das funktioniert das war
hat ziemlich simpel
glaube ich dass das irgendwie so ging
man muss es jetzt einfach durchleiten das war nicht war nicht sonderlich schwierig
ach nee moment moment so einfach ist es doch nicht
wenn ich das jetzt rumdrehe
auch gott logik spielchen
wenn ich das jetzt rumdrehe passt das hier nicht mehr moment easy easy ganz
einfach mal links an
hier ist eine uhr
das einzige was sich hier deckt ist die uhr
und was heißt ich muss die uhr auf jeden fall auf diese seite machen was
anderes bleibt mir nicht übrig
funktioniert das ganze nicht
hey guck mal
ob noch noch noch noch
der tschüb
oh man
aber wenn ich transferiere in die falsche richtung ich noob
hallo joshi1297
es kann doch nicht so schwierig sein so hier rumdrehen
easy next
was gibt es hier
was hier gleich ist
das buch
das heißt das buch muss auf jeden fall auf die linke seite
uns geht es nicht weiter
wenn das buch auf die linke seite muss
da muss der hase
auch auf die linke seite
wat
ok dann geht es nur so dann geht es nur so
ich hab das gar nicht gelöst jetzt
egal das game mein ich hab's gelöst ist alles gut
ding so das wären dann alle mit denen wir arbeiten können
bereit auf den loch zu drücken
du kennst mich doch ich bin immer bereit
alles klar dann schauen wir mal
was für souvenirs johnny uns vom mond mitgebracht hat
ladies first
diesmal nicht süße
da gucken wir mal ob johnny jetzt auf dem mond war
das hier ist dasselbe umgebung wie in der letzten echten erinnerung auf die
wir zugriff haben
normalerweise müsste sich doch wenigstens etwas geändert haben
irgendwas stimmt nicht
diese erinnerungen sie fühlen sich nicht so an als wären sie einfach noch
einmal passiert
die sind exakt die gleichen
unmöglich das verlangen wurde doch transferiert zum mond zu fliegen oder
etwa nicht
doch wurde es
aber es funktioniert nicht
und funktioniert es nicht
das ist genau das gleiche wie da
johnny
was für eine schöne überraschung wir haben seltenen besuch
das ist genau das gleiche
mein name ist doch der eva rosalie
und das ist
was ich sage das jetzt nicht zwei mal
doch der nahe was
ist in der name siegmund hc of life generation geläufig oja
also sie beiden sind von der agentur
das ist genau das gleiche noch mal das trifft sich gut ich habe gerade überlegt
sie anzurufen
willi bringt uns doch bitte etwas t
also es hat sich nichts geändert
frier auch ein
und jetzt
warte hier ich gehe jetzt und sende das verlangen signal noch einmal
pass auf ob sie etwas ändert
die übertragung war definitiv erfolgreich
hat sich was geändert
nicht einmal ein bisschen
wie ist das möglich selbst wenn das verlangen allein nicht ausreicht warum
ändert sich dann gar nichts
vielleicht braucht es einfach etwas stimulation um in gang zu kommen
aus seinen früheren erinnerungen
so früh wir zurückgehen können
der auf gehts
hallo tschüssi pro
johnny's wunsch zum mond zu fliegen braucht etwas stimulation
also dann
ob wir stimulieren
was zum
an der kasse haben sie gesagt dass ein anderer film läuft
egal
macht es dir was aus river
ich mag diesen auch
ok dann lasst uns reingehen
sie versuchen jetzt sie versuchen jetzt irgendwie einzuhämmern dass er zum mond
fliegen will und astronaut wird
hoffentlich reicht das für die zündung
wo ist eigentlich nahe
hier ist er nicht
was gibt das jetzt zum mond liebling
ohenry
was das für ein film
ok ich bin viel zu angespannt um hohenkirchen mit zu kommen zu werden
wahrscheinlich sollte ich mal nachsehen ob sich schon irgendwas ob sich bei john
irgendwas verändert hat
Irgendetwas verändert hat
Lasst mich ran es hat sich nichts geändert
Nope
Alles unverändert. Ich muss versuchen irgendwie das anders zu machen.
Vielleicht kann man hier etwas versuchen.
Was macht eigentlich der Schnabeltier?
Steht da rum
Was macht ihr denn noch hier?
Es geht gleich los. Wenn wir uns nicht beeilen, sind die guten Plätze weg.
Okay, dann werden wir ihm jetzt beibringen, dass er auf den Mond, dass er Astronaut werden soll.
Das habe ich anders in Erinnerung. Es muss sich etwas verändert haben.
Hey nicht drängeln
Da macht Nile jetzt bestimmt irgendwie eine Show oder sowas
Moment mal
Das ist keine echte Änderung, das ist
Darf ich um eure Aufmerksamkeit bitten?
Wie ihr wisst bin ich repräsentant der Kloriosen der Hase
Und ich bin heute hier um euch alles darüber zu erzählen
Hau rein Timmy
Aber ich schweife ab
Sie wollen mich jetzt ernsthaft eingelassen zu Hause werden.
Wie auch immer, ich weiß, dass sich viele von euch eine Frage stellen.
Wie groß ist die Chance, dass ich jemals etwas großartiges machen kann, wie zu einem Abenteuer in neue Welten aufzubrechen?
Den süßen Duft der Venus schnuppern gegen den Uhrzeigersinn durch die Ringe des Saturns zu schwimmen.
Oder vielleicht einfach ein bisschen auf der dunklen Seite des Mondes abzuhängen.
Und dann kann er glauben, dass jeder dazu das Zeug kann, wenn er sich nur richtig anstrengt.
Du könntest es sein.
Oder du.
Oder vielleicht du.
Das wird auch nicht funktionieren.
Aber ich möchte gar nicht zum Mond.
Sogar Johnny sagt hier zu dem Zeitpunkt, er will nicht zum Mond.
Dann ist heute dein Glückstag.
Moment, was? Wieso nicht?
Wieso willst du nicht zum Mond?
Was soll ich da?
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt will Johnny auch nicht auf den Mond.
Ich bin glücklich hier auf der Erde.
Du willst überhaupt nicht hin?
Nicht mal ein kleines bisschen auf den Mond?
Nein, warum?
Nicht mal ein kleines bisschen?
Nun, als offizieller NASA-Rekrutierungsoffizier erzähle ich dir jetzt ein paar unglaubliche Fakten über den Mond.
Sinds trete auf.
Um warm zu werden, der Mond ist 4,5 Milliarden Jahre alt.
Residenz Lieber, Residenz Lieber.
Und wusstet ihr, dass seine Oberfläche so groß wie der afrikanische Kontinent ist?
Doch wirklich, wenn ich das bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Es wird Johnny nicht überzeugen.
Und weiter, das Licht braucht bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Das wusste ich schon.
Und das Beste zu plus.
Leute, die zum Mond fliegen, werden reich und berühmt.
Wir alle kennen die Gleichung, reich plus berühmt gleich Groupies.
Denkt dran, bei der NASA seid ihr alle willkommen.
Besonders daran, wenn ihr prünett seid.
Es zieht alles nicht bei Johnny.
Johnny will nicht mehr zum Mond.
Zumindest kleiner Johnny will nicht zum Mond.
Na, wie war ich?
Die NASA wird dich wahrscheinlich nicht anheuern.
Ich habe alles gegeben.
Willst du mal nachsehen, ob es was gebracht hat?
Natürlich, bin gleich zurück.
Es hat natürlich nichts gebracht, ne?
Wenn ich jetzt mal rate, bin zurück.
Erzähl, grandioser Fehlschlag.
FacePalm, nicht gut.
Hey, lass dich nicht entmutigen.
Ich bin sicher, dass wir immer noch was machen können.
Und das wäre?
Tja.
Wir können uns nicht leisten, dieses Haus fertig zu bauen, Isabelle.
Er will ihn wirklich krampfhaft davon überzeugen.
Aber können sie sich die Mondlandungslotterie leisten?
Er will ihn ernsthaft überzeugen, auf dem Mond zu fliegen.
Aber will nicht.
Die Diagnose steht fest.
Ja, genau genommen haben wir nur selten.
Hey!
Wussten Sie, dass die Mitarbeiter der NASA
exzellente Krankenversicherungsleistungen bekommen?
Tatsächlich.
Sie beide und ihre Liebste.
Voll die Reiten für lau im All.
Es zieht alles nicht.
Zieh mal alle in eine Hochzeit.
Tolle Sache.
Wir sind von der NASA.
Ratet mal, wo ihr ganz mondän Flitterwochen machen könnt.
Es zieht einfach nicht.
Johnny will nicht.
River?
Verdammt rutschig.
Johnny!
Was zur Kurke?
Ha, knapp.
Weißt du was? Es klappt einfach nicht.
Das ist mehr als einfach nicht klappen lassen.
Das ist lächerlich.
Wir sind Profis, verdammt. Ich mach diesen Job nicht,
um die Gegend zu rennen und Leute anzuschreien.
Nicht?
Ich glaube, es liegt einfach an unserem verdammt langen Tag.
Hätte ich gewusst, dass wir die Nacht durcharbeiten,
hätte ich Kaffee mitgenommen. Absolut.
Du hättest mal den Film sehen sollen, den ich vorhin verbrochen habe.
Welcher Film?
Siehst du, das meine ich.
So kostbar unsere Zeit hier auch ist.
In diesem Zustand kommen wir einfach nicht weiter.
Machen wir Pause bis morgen früh.
Hoffentlich hält Johnny bis dahin durch.
Ich muss ein paar Anrufe machen.
Gigi, it's...
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Wieso hat die Maschine nicht funktioniert?
Johnnys Wunsch zum Mond zu fliegen wurde erfolgreich übertragen.
Und trotzdem gab es nach dem Transfer kein einziges Anzeichen dafür,
dass er zum Mond wollte.
Es sei denn, eine zweite Bedingung für seine Sehnsucht wurde dabei mit geändert.
Nur dann könnte der gleiche Wunsch zu zwei verschiedenen Ergebnissen
an unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten führen.
Ohne Zweifel spielt River eine wichtige Rolle bei der ganzen Sache.
Wenn es also irgendwas gibt, was diese Veränderung verursacht haben kann,
dann wäre sie die Hauptverdächtige.
Aber was genau ist die Ursache?
River, was genau hast du getan?
Sie baut Papierhasen.
Und wir wissen immer noch nicht warum.
Ah, die Sonne geht auf.
Wir haben nicht mal viel Zeit.
Ich frage mich, ob Nile etwas herausgefunden hat.
So wie ich Nile kenne, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Außer dumme Sprüche zu machen.
Man kann als Eichhörnchen bis hierher riechen.
Wo ist Nile jetzt?
Stellt es da hier irgendwo rum?
Wie geht es John? Wir verlieren ihn. Was treiben sie dann?
Wir sind einfach nicht vorwärts gekommen.
Tun sie etwas. Wir haben nicht mal viel Zeit.
Falls sie ihren Kollegen suchen, er ist in der Küche.
Ach guck mal, das sind die leeren Bilder, wo Johnny vorhin davor stand.
Und da ist auch dieses komische Schnabel hier wieder drauf.
Scheint echt wichtig zu sein. Ist die Küche hier gewesen?
Oder ist die Küche unten?
Nee, das ist das Klo.
Aber das ist kein 3000 Euro Klo.
Das habe ich gleich fachmännisch im Blick analysiert.
Wo ist denn Nile?
Wie heißt er eigentlich?
Da ist er.
Nein, den Teil verstehe ich, aber...
Okay, hast du das in den Akten gecheckt?
Und warum nochmal wurden uns diese Informationen verschwiegen?
Oder dem Arzt in diesem Fall?
Woher hast du den Kaffee?
Ruisch.
Sprichst du mit der Zentrale?
Ja, ich erkläre es dir später.
Also Ruhe.
Okay, was mache ich jetzt bis Nile fertig telefoniert hat?
Wo geht es denn hier lang?
Wir gehen mal kurz durchs Haus ein bisschen gucken.
Das Bad.
Wo sind eigentlich die Kinder?
Guck mal Mama, ich will nicht zur Schule.
Es ist Sonntag.
Easy.
Lass sie schlafen.
Ich sage nichts.
Gibt es hier irgendwas?
Das Buch ins Regal.
Okay, wann ist denn Nile fertig telefoniert?
Ist er fertig?
Was hat denn Lilly zu der ganzen Sache zu sagen?
Hallo, ich will mit dir reden.
Was soll ich in das Bad gehen?
Ja, neben Platz.
Ich glaube ich habe sie verbackt.
Die Truhe ist verschlossen.
Häh, kriegt man das auf?
Oh, wollen sie mich noch was fragen?
Lilly, Tommy, ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Oh, hey.
Bevor Johnny das Bewusstsein verlor, erzählte er mir, dass sie beide bald eintreffen würden.
Er sagte, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht mehr selbst die Gelegenheit dazu haben würde.
Warte an mich, Ihnen zu danken.
Also, vielen Dank.
Gucken wir mal, ob Nile fertig telefoniert ist.
Ja, Eva, geh da mal rein.
Was ist?
Erscheinen als gäbe es vertrauliche Akten zu Johnnys Kindheit.
Vertrauliche Krankenakten, um genau zu sein.
Offenbar hat er während seiner Kindheit eine nicht unbeträchtliche Menge an Beta Blockern verabreicht bekommen.
Und was für ein Zufall, die haben ein kleines bisschen Nebenwirkung auf so komische Dinge namens Gedächtnis.
Beta Blocker?
Johnny hatte keine Herzprobleme, oder?
Anscheinend nicht.
Was uns zur Frage führt, ob diese Nebenwirkungen nicht die eigentliche Absicht waren.
Vor allem bei derart großen Mengen, der Einfluss auf sein Erinnerungsvermögen muss immens gewesen sein.
Du meinst, das hat uns den Weg zu den Kindheitserinnerungen versperrt?
Das ist jedenfalls kein Maschinenfehler, so viel kann ich dir sagen.
Die IT-Abteilung hat mich ganz schön angemolzt, weil ich sie beschuldigt habe.
Und was jetzt?
Na rein in die Maschine!
Ich habe die Frequenz-Modifikationen bekommen, mit denen können wir die Barriere überwinden.
Und wenn wir erstmal in seiner Kindheit angekommen sind, ist es sicher früh genug, um den Wunsch erfolgreich zu übertragen.
Worauf warten wir dann?
Es gibt noch eine Sache.
Es gibt immer noch eine Sache.
Um die neue Frequenz zu aktivieren, brauchen wir einen Auslöser.
Einen Auslöser?
Etwas in den versperrten Erinnerungen, das sehr stark präsent ist.
Und wir müssen es Johnny geben, damit er seine Erinnerung wecken kann.
Und wie sollen wir das machen? Wir wissen so gut wie nicht über seine Kindheit.
Und selbst wenn wir ein Kindheitsfoto fänden, ist Johnny nach wie vor bewusstlos.
Ja, also sind wir keinen Schritt weiter.
Weißt du, seit Neuras Fall letztes Jahr hatten wir keinen Auftrag mehr, der mich so saumäßig genervt hat.
Geht mir genauso.
Das bringt mich nur um. Ich gehe mal etwas frische Luft schnappen.
Gut.
Nein, mach das.
Da ist er wieder. Hat meinen Kaffee vergessen.
Alter Lan.
Ich gehe ihm jetzt mal hinterher.
Es stinkt, ja nach dem Eichhörnchen, was er überfahren hat.
Das überfahrene Tier, Eva, es stinkt.
Ich weiß, daran bist du schuld. Du hast es überfahren.
Was ist los? Die Kinder schlafen noch.
Moment mal.
Letzte Erinnerung, die wo wir feststecken.
Sie hatte denselben Geruch. Wie das überfahrene Tier.
Worüber reden sie beide?
Die Geruchsrezeptoren sind direkt mit dem olympischen System des Gens verbunden, Lilly.
Äh, wat? Verstehen sie nicht?
Auch egal.
Er meint, dass der Geruchssinn wahrscheinlich der effektivste Sinn ist, um Erinnerung zu wecken.
Wir können den Geruch als Stimulation nutzen, um einen Weg zu seinen Kindheitserinnerungen freizulegen.
Alter, wollen sie jetzt Johnny entver...
Johnny hat noch ein, zwei Tage zu leben, ja?
Und sie wollen ihm ein verwestes Eichhörnchen aufs Bett legen.
Obwohl Johnny bewusstlos ist, ist er immer noch empfänglich dafür.
Ich glaube, ich hab den Zusammenhang nicht kapiert.
Okay, das ist gut. Das ist fantastisch.
Jetzt muss ich nur mal was von dem überfahrenden Eichhörnchen holen.
Ja, ich werde... Moment mal. Warum sollte ich das dir holen?
Du hast es überfahren. Genau. Ich hab meinen Beitrag geleistet.
Oh, du Spast.
Sie können meine Handschuhe haben.
Es sind zwar eigentlich keine Wegwerfhandschuhe, aber das wird danach vermutlich ändern.
So, wir speichern mal.
So, gehen wir das überfahrene Eichhörnchen holen.
Guck, sie hat sogar Handschuhe an.
Oh man, soll ich jetzt da runterlaufen?
Noch mehr Eichhörnchen.
Dann gehen wir mal das Eichhörnchen holen.
Das ist zu gefährlich. Naja.
Okay, dann schmeißen wir es in die Box.
Sie wollen allen Ernstes schon hier ein totes Eichhörnchen auf... Naja.
Ihr wollt was? Ihr wollt eine Pause machen?
Ja, dann geht mal kurz aufs Klo.
Geht mal kurz aufs Klo. Ich mach kurz Pause.
Ich denke mal, das Spiel geht wahrscheinlich noch so ne...
Wie lang wird... Wie lang geht das ungefähr noch? Ich würd mal sagen so 45 Minuten.
Stunde. Stunde. 45 Minuten bis Stunde.
Ja, auf geht's Leute. Kurz Pause. Dann geht's weiter.
Dann gehen wir alle aufs Klo.
Geh ich auch mal.
So, ich bin wieder am Start.
Ich warte jetzt noch ein, zwei Minuten, dass die Leute vom Klo wiederkommen können.
Dann geht's weiter.
Grad mal kurz gucken, was auf YouTube so abgeht.
Wie mein neues Video einfach schon mal 15k Aufrufe innerhalb von ein paar Stunden hat, einfach nur weil der Cheater im Titel steht.
Dabei wollte ich das Video gar nicht freischalten.
Und 330 Kommentare hat. Lull.
Eine Minute noch.
Ist ein gutes Video. Ja, mir hat die Aufnahme nicht gefallen. Deswegen wollte ich es nicht freischalten.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, also warum ich das Video heute freigeschaltet habe. Ich glaube, das Problem war, dass ich beim Upload normalerweise habe ich standardmäßig eingestellt, dass beim Video Upload das auf Privat gestellt wird.
Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich wahrscheinlich es nicht, also irgendwie von Privat auf halt nicht mehr Privat gestellt beim Upload.
Und dann hat das Video halt verarbeitet und sich quasi nach dem Verarbeiten selbst freigeschaltet.
Deswegen hatte das Video auch kein Titel und keine Videobeschreibung so richtig.
Sondern, sondern halt nur so meine Standard Video Beschreibung, die ich reinmache, dass ich dran denke, die Links in die Beschreibung zu kopieren und auf Gameplayerspieler zu verlinken.
Der Titel war ja auch einfach nur Cheater.Waff, äh nicht Waff, äh MKV.
Max wird mal in der näher Zukunft ein Video zum Thema Kryptowährung sehen. Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Wahrscheinlich. So Leute, alle wieder da.
Wo gehen sie hin? Klo-Pause, ja das passt doch.
So Leute, alle wieder am Start.
Wann kommt der Max-FPS-Coin? Ich bin eher der Meinung, er sollte den Wupplas-Coin machen. Das klingt viel besser.
Weiter geht's. Lily, wo gehen sie hin?
Ich. Für kleine Doktor.
Der hat's aber eilig.
Pures Chaos. Der Aufbruch hat alle zueinander geworfen. Mal sehen.
Kram, kram, kram. Hier ist die Box. Hermetisch versiegelbare Box erhalten.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch was von dem überfallenen Eichhörnchen.
Komm, noch mehr reinpacken.
Okay, dann gehen wir mal zurück zum Haus.
Und setzen Johnny, der nur noch einen Tag zu leben hat, ungefähr ein verwesstes Eichhörnchen.
Teile von einem verwessten Eichhörnchen aufs Bett. Wie in echt.
Also Leute, ich denke das Game dauert noch so ungefähr 45 Minuten.
Das sind die schlimmsten 45 Minuten. Es gibt kaum ein Game, das mich emotional so mitgenommen hat wie die letzte Stunde vor dem Game.
Hi. Hast du das überfallene Tier mitgebracht? Alles bereit.
Schön. Dann leg schon mal los, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Wo gehst du hin?
Ich muss meinen Tamagotchi füttern.
Was? What?
Wirklich Schwester. Ich hatte eben so ein Retro-Feeling.
Wie auch immer, beeil dich, mach alles fertig. Ich bin 0,0x wieder da. Mach du mal.
Beeil dich, da drüben stirbt gleich jemand.
Was hat er vor?
Ich habe keine Zeit hier hinterher zu laufen.
Da ist er.
Wenn wir an exakt diesem Punkt angekommen sind, gebe ich das Signal.
Sobald ich das tue, öffnen Sie bitte das Ventil für etwa 3 Sekunden. Jawoll.
Wurde aber auch Zeit, dass du auftauchst. Sicher, dass keine Keime entweichen können.
Alles versiegelt und durchgefiltert. Nicht, dass es einem toten Mann noch viel ausmachen würde.
Sie sollten wissen, dass sich Jollys Zustand rapide verschlechtert.
Es könnte ihre letzte Chance sein.
Was immer Sie beide da drin vorhaben, ich wünsche Ihnen viel Glück.
Glück ist das letzte, was wir jetzt brauchen.
Jetzt geht's zur Sache.
Dritter Akt. Sie senden ihr Licht zu den anderen Leuchttürmen und zu mir.
Wir sind wieder bei Johnny daheim.
Gehen wir.
Ja, hier haben wir aufgehört.
Hol schon mal die Taschentücher raus. Die letzte Stunde ist wirklich schlimm.
Es war ein kleines Ding und es macht uns so viel Ärger.
Ich könnte es zum Mond schießen.
Schätze, wir können jetzt nur noch das Signal senden und hoffen.
Gut, bereit.
So, dann stinkt mal Johnny mit dem Eichhörnchen ein.
Irgendwas passiert. Schnell, sende es nochmal.
Was ist los?
Da stimmt was nicht.
Übernehmen Sie für mich, Lilly.
Sein Zustand hat sich destabilisiert. Ich muss die Medikation anpassen.
Was passiert hier? Er ist instabil geworden.
Raus hier.
Was? Nein, wir gehen nicht raus. Raus aus seinem Gedächtnis sofort.
Wieso? Solange das System so instabil ist, kann jeder, der sich hier befindet, bleibenden Schaden nehmen.
Du machst Witze. Warum lockst du dich da nicht aus?
Ich kann nicht, Nal. Wenn wir uns beide ausloggen, ist unsere bisherige Arbeit verloren.
Warum auch immer.
Und wir haben nicht mehr genug Zeit, alles nochmal zu machen, bevor Johnny stirbt.
Ach du Scheiße. Erzähl mir doch keinen Mist.
Wir sind hier nicht im Kinofilm. Du bist nicht die Heldin. Du bist einfach nur bescheuert.
Aber du bist der Held, oder wie?
Mach, dass du rauskommst. Vergiss es.
Wenn du weg bist, stecken sie mich wahrscheinlich in ein Team mit Ali-Stair.
Alter, ich verstehe die Witze von Nal nicht.
Weißt du, wie der Mann stinkt?
Schlimmer als das überfahrene Vieh.
Verdammt, Nal. Das habe ich nun davon, dass ich dir geholfen habe, dich durch den Eignungs-Test zu muggeln.
Der Doktor, der hat es hingekriegt.
Übrigens, im Nachfolger ist der gleiche Doktor am Start, sieht noch genauso aus und heißt auch einfach nur Doktor.
Alles im Griff, vorerst.
So, haben wir es geschafft.
Weißt du was? Dein Karottenkuchen ist ekelhaft.
Ja, und bei der letzten Weihnachtsfeier hattest du...
Komm, lass uns gehen, bevor das nochmal passiert.
Weißt du, ich habe das nicht wirklich so gemeint, also, dass du bescheuert bist.
Ich allerdings schon.
Da gucken wir mal jetzt an, was in Johnnys Kindheit passiert ist.
Ah, ich muss zum Ball.
Augen zu und durch.
Wir haben es geschafft.
In Johnnys Kindheit. Es hat funktioniert, ich kann es kaum glauben.
Wir sind also tatsächlich durch. Aber ich bin mir jetzt nicht mehr sicher, ob es mir hier gefallen wird.
Wieso? Sieht doch alles ganz friedlich aus.
Nal, vorhin in Johnnys Zimmer. Ist dir da etwas seltsames aufgefallen?
Äh, was denn?
Da war etwas seltsames. Hast du es nicht gesehen?
Ich, ich glaube nicht.
Schon gut. Ich hoffe nur, dass ich unrecht habe.
Wow, das klingt fabelhaft.
Ich weiß. Okay, irgendwann musst du mich mal dort... Was? Irgendwann musst du sie mal dort hin mitnehmen? Ich kann nicht mehr lesen.
Fail.
Die Zeitüberlappung gerät außer Kontrolle. Sieh dir mal an, wie viele Exemplare von ihm hier sind. Es ist ein regelrechter Johnny-Zoo.
Äh, ha?
Da ist der Ball.
Johnny, bleibst du stehen?
Sieht so aus, als würde der Ball sich von alleine bewegen. Guck mal, ein Eichhörnchen.
Sieh mal auf die Uhr. Wir sind so spät dran. Ich mach mich besser auf den Weg. Das Geschäft macht heute früher zu.
Äh, pass auf dich auf.
Grüß die Jungs von mir.
Mach ich. Wir sehen uns.
Tja, das ist wohl eine Sackgasse. Und worauf wolltest du hinaus?
Vergiss es einfach. Vielleicht hatte ich auch mal unrecht.
Er ist so friedlich. In dieser Erinnerung existiert nichts, was so etwas auslösen könnte, außer...
Verdammt. Wir müssen umkehren. Sofort.
Moment mal, was denn jetzt schon wieder? Halt einfach die Klappe, komm mit.
Halt die Klappe.
Komm mit.
Ich verstehe das nicht. Er war bewusstlos. Wie können wir das hier sehen, wenn er es selbst nicht einmal gesehen hat?
Jedenfalls ist es ein Wunder, dass er überlebt hat. Eigentlich hat er das ja auch gar nicht.
Äh, wie kann Johnny das nicht überlebt haben? Er ist ja noch da.
Hast du dir sein Zimmer nicht angesehen, Niall? Johnny hat... Johnny hatte ein Etagenbett.
Joey!
Joey, kannst du mich hören? Deswegen nennt ihn seine Mutter auch immer Joey.
Warum hast du Joey überfahren, Mama? Ach, das ist auch noch die Mutter.
Das hab ich vom ersten Mal durchspielen gar nicht gecheckt.
Das ist die Mutter von ihm auch noch.
Jetzt ergibt es ja noch mehr Sinn, dass die Mutter ihn jetzt Joey nennt.
Warum hast du ihn überfahren? Wach auf, Joey.
Wach auf.
Joey, geht der Chat noch oder seid ihr alle so gespannt dabei und sagt nichts?
Wenn sie noch so klein waren, einen Zwillingsbruder zu verlieren, ganz davon abgesehen, wie sich die Mutter fühlen musste.
Wenigstens hatte Johnny die Beta Blocker, um die Erinnerung auszulöschen.
Nicht, dass da noch viel wäre.
Nur ein Koppel nicht gelöscht. Irgendwo hier drin hat ein Nachhall dieser Erinnerung wahrscheinlich weiter existiert.
Wir wissen übrigens immer noch nicht, warum er zum Mond will.
Was ist mit der Mutter?
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie Beta Blocker genommen hat. Sieht aus, als wäre sie ein wenig durchgedreht.
Zumindest glaube ich nicht mehr, dass Joey nur ihr Spitzname für Johnny war.
Aber wenn sie Johnny als Ersatz für Joey nimmt, was ist dann mit Johnny selbst?
Mir gefällt das hier nicht, lass uns gehen.
Das ist nicht die einzige abgekoppelte Erinnerung.
Seltsam, es baut keine Barriere mehr auf. Mal nicht den Teufel an die Wand.
Kleiner Johnny und Joey.
Man, das musst du unbedingt auch mal lesen.
Ich meine, echt jetzt, diese Serie ist einfach nur genial. Ich habe schon drei Bücher einfach so weggelesen.
Johnny, was liest du denn?
Animorphs.
Ja, das fand Johnny später auch geil.
Es geht um eine Gruppe von Kindern, die sich in Tiere verwandeln und gegen Schnecken kämpfen, die deine Gedanken kontrollieren.
Klingt nach einer tollen Story.
Ach, diese seltsamen Alienzeugs ist nichts für mich.
Wieso nicht? Das ist der Hammer.
Schaut euch mal übrigens den Rucksack an, den hat er später immer noch.
Statt zur langweiligen Schule zu gehen, könnten sie Tiger werden, die große böse Aliens in Stücke reißen.
Dabei machen sie immer so, ich mach das jetzt mal nicht nach, so wie Tiger halt machen, wenn man das schreibt.
Und dann kriegen sie Laser und dann alle BÄM in your face.
BÄM BÄM BÄM BÄM
Lass das, Lull.
Du wirst schon sehen, Johnny.
Eines Tages werde ich ein berühmter Autor.
Dann schreibe ich die coolste Geschichte überhaupt und alle Kinder kriegen mein Buch umsonst.
Ich werde uns reich machen, dann kaufe ich dir und Mama eine dicke Villa.
Wie willst du uns reich machen, wenn die Bücher umsonst sind?
Umsonst für die Kinder, die Eltern müssen zahlen, ist doch klar.
Klar, ich bin ganz sicher, dass die Eltern dir das Geld hinterher schmeißen werden.
Was ist, bist du immer noch sauer wegen, neulich?
Jetzt komm schon, ich hab als erster gesagt, dass ich den Zug haben will.
Das war alles ganz fair.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Preis passiert?
Äh, was ist eigentlich mit deinem Preis passiert?
Hab ich verschenkt.
An einen Penner.
Ach, pass auf, es geht nicht nur um neulich.
Du weißt, dass du immer Mamas Liebling warst.
Hey, das ist doch gar nicht wahr.
Erinnerst du dich an letzte Weihnachten?
Und letzte Ostern?
Und als wir Angeln waren und und und?
Okay, weißt du was?
Du kannst meinen Zug haben, wenn du willst.
Echt jetzt?
Ja, hier, nehme den Zug.
Ich meine, nach deiner Logik wird sie mir ja einfach einen neuen kaufen, oder?
Hör mal, Johnny, welchen Unterschied macht es schon, wem von uns was gehört?
Alles, was meinst, ist auch deins.
Ich meine, wir können doch beide damit spielen, oder?
Stimmt.
Siehst du?
Ich meine, du bist mein Zwillingsbruder, Mann.
Alter Lan, du bist wie ein Teil von mir.
Ey komm, lass uns die Nachbarn ärgern.
Warte mal, im Regen?
Klar, auf geht's.
Die Morphs.
Nicht genug Memory Links?
Doch, klar.
So, und jetzt werden wir langsam verstehen, was Sache ist.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das ist somit die Schlüsselszene in dem Game.
So eine Art Ja-Markt oder nicht?
Sollen wir uns ein wenig umsehen?
Wie wäre es, wenn ich mich umsehe und du hier einfach stehen bleibst?
Wie wäre es, wenn wir uns eine Stunde lang nur noch in Frageform unterhalten,
mehr aufzuquatschen und gehe?
Jetzt hast du es vermasselt.
Tomaten sind keine Früchte.
Na, haben sie auch eingelegte Gurken?
Ja, ich will jetzt nicht wissen, was Tomaten sind.
Kleiner Johnny und kleiner Joey.
Aber ich will dieses blöde Ding nicht.
Ich will den Zug.
Wir haben nur noch einen Zug.
Willst du deinen Preis vielleicht stattdessen gegen einen Teddybär tauschen?
Nein, ich will den Zug.
Na, komm schon.
Johnny, mach keine Szene.
Joey hat ihn zuerst gewonnen, fair und gerecht oder einfach nicht.
Aber ich habe auch gewonnen, nur weil er vor mir dran war.
Lull.
Ist schon okay, du darfst auch damit spielen.
Siehst du, wie nett von deinem Bruder Johnny.
Ich will den Zug.
Okay, ihr Hilfeklose.
Blockiert mal nicht den ganzen Stand.
Komm, wir schauen mal, was es da drüben gibt.
Ich bin kein Hilfeklose.
Weißt du was?
Ab jetzt nenne ich dich nur noch Hilfeklösschen.
Verarsch mich nicht.
Ah ja, das Schicksal hat wundervolle Fügungen für euch bereit.
Aus diesem hier könnt ihr Anwalt werden und aus diesem hier ein Arzt.
TF, kommt ihr zwei, ich kaufe euch Süßigkeiten.
Hey, wo ist mein Trinkgeld?
Wo ist Johnny hin?
Dafuck.
Wo ist er hin?
Ah, hier.
Das werden dreimal, wenn du links beleuchtest.
Okay, ich habe sie übersehen.
Wo ist sie denn?
Äh, bin ich blind?
Ah, hier runter.
Was?
Dafuck?
Moment.
Hä?
Was übersehe ich denn jetzt gerade?
Klopft den was?
Klopft den Maulwurf.
Ist das nicht Tierquälerei?
Das sind ja auch keine echten Maulwürfe.
Genau.
So haben die Leute Dampf abgelassen, bevor Ego-Shooter erfunden wurden.
Primitiv.
Ganz schön ghetto, Alter.
Wo hast du davon gelesen?
Mein Opa war ein Fan davon.
Wollen sie ein Spielchen wagen?
Einfach alle Köpfe klopfen und teure Preise gewinnen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Oh nein.
WTF?
Nein.
Ich will nicht Hammer spielen.
Äh, hallo?
Oh, nee.
Was zum Teufel mit dem Steuer?
Ach du Scheiß.
Was ist das für eine dämliche Steuerung?
Ich muss das mit der Maus machen, doch nicht mit der Tastatur.
Ist das denn total hängen geblieben, das Ding?
Mit der Tastatur?
Ich kann das nicht mit der Maus steuern.
Das ist ja Fail.
Ich kann ja gar nicht mein krasses Flick-Aim verwenden.
Das ist ja anstrengend.
Und die Steuerung ist übrigens ungenau.
Okay, Zeit ist um.
Easy.
Reicht.
Das ergibt 61%.
Das ist ein neuer Rekord.
Was?
Okay.
Okay, dafür gab es einen Memorelink.
Ich musste das also machen.
Okay, gut.
Gut zu wissen.
Nein.
Was muss ich denn machen?
Die Steuerung hast du gewählt.
Ja, okay, stimmt.
Ich habe einfach Escape gedrückt.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich drei Memorelinks?
Ich habe zwei Memorelinks.
Okay, ein Memorelink fehlt noch.
Ich...
Sag mal, bin ich irgendwie blind oder was?
Moment, wo muss ich denn jetzt was machen?
Dem Typ habe ich doch schon geredet.
Ach, hier unten.
Willkommen, ich präsentiere das kleinste Riesenrad der Welt.
Ja, ist sehr groß.
Können wir eine Probefahrt machen?
Natürlich nicht.
Funktioniert das überhaupt?
Einfach ein paar Stühle dran geklebt.
Ja, es sieht nicht wirklich aus wie ein Riesenrad.
Okay, weiter geht es.
Wir haben drei Memorelinks.
Beide gehen wir jetzt da lang?
Oder gehen wir da lang?
Ich könnte sagen, es macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied.
Wir gehen jetzt hier lang.
Weil in die Richtung sind sie auch gelaufen.
Ja.
Gibt es hier?
Kleiner Joey, kleiner Johnny.
Hapa, hapa.
Ich werde dich nie verstehen, Joey.
Wie kannst du nur diesen Geschmack ertragen?
Sie sind so sauer.
Sie futtern Gurken.
Johnny ist später immer mehr zu Joey geworden und gar nicht mehr er selbst.
Er hat sogar Gurken gefuttert, obwohl er Gurken nicht mochte.
Beziehungsweise er konnte sich ja nicht mehr erinnern und seine Mutter hat ihn quasi einfach
so erzogen zu Joey.
Sauer und super.
Das sind sie.
Probier doch mal.
Näh.
Bäh.
Könntest du wenigstens eine probieren, Johnny?
Wer weiß.
Vielleicht kommst du damit auch auf den Geschmack.
Genau.
Näh.
Ich bin fertig, Mama.
Kann ich spielen gehen?
Okay, aber nur auf dem Spielplatz.
Nicht einen Meter weiter.
Gib mir die Tasche.
Ich pass für dich darauf auf.
Nein, das ist meins.
Habe ich gewonnen.
Eingelegte Oliven.
Gehen wir mal Johnny hinterher.
Fünf mehr nur links.
Okay, ich muss noch irgendwas anklicken.
Warte, muss ich anklicken.
Äh.
Was gibt's denn hier noch?
Was muss ich denn hier noch machen?
Das glitzert so, da muss ich doch bestimmt hin, oder was ist hier?
Ah, ich hab's.
Easy.
Einfach langlaufen.
Okay, gehen wir mal Joey hinterher.
Äh, Johnny.
Jetzt bring ich das auch schon einmal durch.
Da steht er ja.
Vor allem, wo geht der hin?
Er darf doch nur auf den Spielplatz, aber natürlich hört er wieder auf seine Mutter,
nicht?
Aber er macht das in dem Alter schon.
Auf einmal hören wir nicht so gut, was?
Wo will er denn hin?
Wow.
Ja, da hat er Sebaro recht.
Wir werden gleich erfahren, warum Johnny zum Mond will.
Okay, er hat den Weg ver- äh, okay, er hat den Weg verlassen und einen coolen Ort gefunden.
Aber seien wir ehrlich, der hätte ebenso gut von einem hudelten Tiger angefallen werden
können.
Tiger leben nicht in hudelnden Dorfkopf.
Das war auch nur eine Redensart.
Weißt du, als ich noch klein war, hat mich mein Opa jedes Jahr zum Sternengucken mitgenommen.
Ja.
Es gab einen Hügel außerhalb der Stadt, wo wir immer standen.
Dasselbe Hügel jedes Jahr.
Wir schauen, was Little Sam so mir fällt gerade erstmal auf, dass du den Hintergrund hier
aus dem Spiel hast.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab nur den Hintergrund mit Mond und Stern gesucht.
Wir schauen in die Sterne, bis dann morgen, der Mathe.
Und ja, ich schaute hauptsächlich.
Er hat nur das Teleskop für mich getragen.
Natürlich.
Nun hätte Mama mir allerdings niemals erlaubt, die ganze Nacht wach zu bleiben.
Deshalb sagte Opa ihr jedes Mal, dass wir nur Zelten fahren und versteckt ihr das Teleskop
im Auto.
Das war toll.
Aber wenn wir am Morgen zurück kamen, wusste ich es wie du, als hätte ich nachts geschlafen.
Und das ist kurz gefasst die Geschichte, wie ich in die Koffeinsucht abdriftete.
Du bist ein Monstrum.
Ich weiß.
Es ist schon sehr traurig.
All diese schönen Erinnerungen verloren und niemals wiedergefunden.
Und wer weiß, wie viele mehr es noch gibt.
Tja, wie du immer sagst, man muss jeden Moment für sich genießen, nicht?
Yo.
Hä?
WTF?
Ich hab dir doch gesagt, hier gibt's Tigerrudel.
Es ist die kleine River.
Daran sieht man, Johnny und River kannten sich schon lange vor der Schule.
Johnny weiß es bloß nicht mehr.
Allerdings, River weiß es noch.
Warte, bleib hier.
Ich bin Johnny und wie heißt du?
Du bist am einen Platz.
Was?
Deinen Platz?
Äh, tut mir leid, ich wollte mich hier nicht ganz alleine ausbreiten.
Willst du dich zu mir setzen?
Bist du hier um die Sterne zu beobachten?
Äh, und du?
Du bist hier um die Sterne zu beobachten?
Schau nur, wusstest du, dass es so viele Lichter am Himmel gibt?
Yo.
Äh, ja wusste ich, ich wusste das auch.
Das ist also dein Platz, ja?
Nur während des Jahrmarkts.
Kein Fan von Menschenmengen?
Bin ich auch nicht.
Weißt du, du hast mir immer noch nicht deinen Namen gesagt.
Ich sag ihn dir auch nicht.
In der Schule machen sich alle darüber lustig.
Warum?
Sie sagen, dass sie aufs Klo müssen, wenn sie an ihn denken.
Äh, aha, ja dann sag ihn mir halt nicht.
Tja, es kann doch eigentlich nichts schlimmer als John sein.
Ich meine, überall auf der Welt heißt fast jeder John.
Auch in Indien?
Das wird mich nicht wundern.
Was ist denn verkehrt daran?
Was ist verkehrt daran, einen Namen zu haben, den jeder hat?
Es ist langweilig, denke ich.
Ich meine, wenn alle so heißen, wo ist denn der Sinn?
Ich hätte nichts dagegen.
Ausnahmsweise mal den gleichen Namen zu haben, den alle anderen auch haben.
Das ist wie mit diesen Lichtern am Himmel.
Von hier unten sehen sie alle gleich aus, aber das macht den einzelnen Sternen kein
bisschen weniger schön.
Ja, vielleicht.
Diese ganzen Sterne da oben, was glaubst du, sind sie?
Mein Vater sagt, sie sind riesige Brändekugeln aus Gas.
Da hat er recht.
Ach, das denkt er sich doch nur aus.
Warum sollte er mich dann anlügen?
Weil, äh, das machen Erwachsene halt, die denken sich komische Sachen aus.
Den Weihnachtsmann, der Osterhase, Kängurus, so Zeug halt.
Hast du schon mal versucht, den Osterhasen aus Sternen zu machen?
Meinst du wie ein Sternbild?
Ja.
Ähm, andere Sachen schon, aber noch nie einen Hase.
Möchtest du einen machen?
Klar, machen wir das beste Sternbild aller Zeiten.
Mal sehen, wer zuerst eins hat.
Okay, von drei, drei, zwei, eins und los, ich seh es.
Tja, River ist schnell mit sowas.
Hä, was, wie, so schnell?
Am Himmel.
Wo genau am Himmel?
Denk in großen Zusammenhängen, Johnny.
Ähm, größer als alle die anderen es tun.
Hä, ich versteh es nicht.
Moment mal, warte mal, ich seh es.
Sag mir, was du siehst.
Da drüben, stimmt's, das sind die zwei Löffel und der Kopf.
Und weiter.
Da sind seine Füße.
Äh, und was noch?
Ihr merkt schon, der ist, die fragt ihn, genau das Gleiche wie bei den Papierhasen,
ne?
Und der Mond.
Und der Mond ist sein großer Unterbauch.
Wir wissen auch immer noch nicht, warum Johnny auf den Mond will, aber ich glaub, dass du
in zwei, drei Dialogboxen erfahren wirst.
Also, was glaubst du, sind sie wirklich?
Die Sterne, mein ich.
Ich, ich habe es noch nie jemandem erzählt, aber ich habe immer gedacht, dass sie Leuchttürme
sind.
Milliarden von Leuchttürmen, die fest sitzen am anderen Ende des Himmels.
Wow, muss ganz schön was los sein da oben.
Ist aber nicht so.
Sie können all die anderen Leuchttürme dort draußen sehen und sie wollen mit ihnen reden.
Aber das können sie nicht, denn sie sind alle viel zu weit voneinander entfernt, um zu
hören, was die anderen sagen.
Sie können nichts tun, außer aus der Ferne ihr Licht schicken.
Also tun sie das.
Sie senden ihr Licht zu den anderen Leuchttürmen und zu mir.
Warum zu dir?
Weil ich eines Tages mit einem von ihnen Freundschaft schließen werde.
Das wissen wir ja, mit Anja später.
Deine Tasche, was ist da drin?
Der Preis, den ich bei Klopp den Maulwurf gewonnen habe.
Hast du schon mal gespielt?
Ich habe es versucht, aber ich bin zu ungeschickt dafür.
Was hast du gekriegt?
Es ist ein Ding.
Ich kann nicht wirklich sagen, was es ist.
So eine Art Entenbiberding.
Darf ich mal sehen?
Es sieht so seltsam aus.
Ich wünschte, ich könnte auch eins gewinnen.
Johnny, wo steckst du denn?
Mama ruft mich, ich muss weg.
Hier nimm es wieder.
Weißt du was, behalt es, es gehört dir.
Mir?
Ja, ich kann jederzeit noch eins gewinnen.
Ich will er nicht angeben, aber ich bin einfach der Beste bei diesem Spiel.
Bist du nächstes Jahr wieder hier?
Ja, du auch?
Klar, selber Ort, selbe Zeit.
Und wenn du es vergisst oder wir uns aus den Augen verlieren?
Das wünsche ich dir, ganz gerne,
Das ist der Grund, warum Johnny auf den Mond will.
Und er kann sich nicht dran erinnern, weil er komische Medikamente nehmen musste und seine
Mutter ihn versucht hat zu Joey umzuerziehen. Und deswegen wollte er in der Schule auch mit River
zusammen sein, weil er die ganze Zeit jemand anderes sein sollte. Aber eigentlich wollte er
nur er sein. Dann treffen wir uns auf dem Mond wieder, Dummelchen. Auf dem Bauch des Hasen.
Erinnert euch noch dran, dass River Johnny einen dicken Hasen gebastelt hat aus dem Papier? Das
ergibt jetzt alles Sinn, oder? Sie wollte ihm das die ganze Zeit erzählen, dass er sich dran
erinnert. Aber er hat's halt nicht mal gecheckt. Johnny, ich bin schon unterwegs. Mein Hackysack
ist noch in der Tasche. Du sagst es, du bist ungestickt, stimmt's? Versuch's damit.
Falls sie sich jemals aus den Augen verlieren. Moment mal, soll das heißen? Sag mir nicht,
du hast das nicht kommen sehen. Und ich hatte schon geglaubt, dass hier würde eine inspirierende
Kindheitstrauma-Geschichte werden. Ich hätte wissen sollen, dass irgendein Mädchen auftaucht und
einen Schmachtfetzen daraus macht. Ich glaube, wir wissen jetzt, was wir tun müssen, um ihn
zum Mond zu bringen. Moment mal, du willst doch nicht etwa das wirklich tun, oder? Es
ist unser Job, Neil. Nein. So lautet unser Auftrag. Verdammt noch mal, Eva. Nein, das kannst du nicht
machen. Eva. Ich weiß, dass du hier irgendwo bist.
Wo hat sich Eva versteckt? Da ist sie. Umdrehen. Neil, ich weiß, was du vorhast. Ich weiß,
dass du das weißt. Ja, und nun, ich weiß, dass du weißt, dass ich weiß. Hör mal,
unser Job ist, ihn zum Mond zu bringen. Und das wird nur dann passieren, wenn Johnny motiviert ist,
dieses Ziel zu verfolgen. Aber wenn wir dafür River entfernen müssten, was soll die Sache dann
überhaupt noch bringen? Er will überhaupt nur deshalb zum Mond, weil sie gestorben ist.
Das ist ihm quasi in dem Moment, wo seine Frau gestorben ist, wieder eingefallen. Unterbewusst.
Er wusste das ja nicht mehr. Wir sind gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet, diesen Vertrag zu erfüllen.
Scheiß auf den Vertrag. Ich habe diesen Job nicht angenommen, um ihm die Lebensfreude zu nehmen,
Eva. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie du das siehst, aber ich mache das hier, damit der alte Knacker mit einem
Lächeln im Gesicht sterben kann. Ich doch auch, und ich mag meinen Job. Aber wenn wir gegen unsere
gesetzlichen Pflichten verstoßen, sehen wir uns vor Gericht wieder. Das werden wir anfechten. Wir
wissen, dass Johnny glücklicher wird, wenn er nicht zum Mond fliegt. Es gibt viele alternative
Lebenstangenten, denen Johnny glücklicher wäre. Wir sind nicht hier, um Gott zu spielen. Es ist
unser Job, ihm zu geben, was er bestellt hat. Zufällig wissen wir aber, was er will. Besser
als er selbst. Verstehe doch, ich riskiere River doch nur deswegen, weil ich an sie glaube. Und
was soll das heißen? Du riskierst sie, du entfernt sie. Außerdem werde ich es wieder gut machen.
Wieder gut machen, wie denn? Uns läuft die Zeit davon nahe. Vertrau mir einfach, sagt die Frau,
die mich von dem Scheißleuchtturm geschubst hat. Verdammte Lichtwerte, mit deinen Chromtun schaltest
du meinen Zugriff nicht vollständig ab, Eva. Versteckte Fallen, wirklich? Ich versuche nur
Zeit zu gewinnen. Danke, dass du Bescheid zeigst. Bewegen. Im Prinzip kann dir in dem Game nichts
passieren. Das ist ziemlich teure Ausrüstung, die du hier durch die Gegend wirfst. Ich meine
das ernst, bleib einfach wo du bist und warte bis ich fertig bin. Ach du kannst mich mal,
ähm, sonst wo. Hier ist nichts. Hör mal, zwing mich nicht dazu hier auszusteigen und dir den
Stecker zu ziehen. Du würdest ernsthaft riskieren, dass seine Erinnerungen in diesem kaputten
Zustand bleiben. Hör einfach auf, bitte, ich brauch nicht lang. Oh nee, schon wieder. Oder
komm doch und hol mich, ich bin am Ende des Flurs. Das weißt du doch nicht ernst. Findest
du das witzig, Eva? Das sind nicht einfach nur Zombie-Evas. Das sind Zombie-Vars. Kein
Schritt näher, ich bin bewaffnet. Was, WASD benutzen? Ah, ok. Alter, die Steuerung, die
Steuerung, die Steuerung ist so fail. Also die Dinger doch zu was gut.
Wie darf? HALT ZU!
Das ist alles nur eine Schleife. Muss ich vielleicht hier runter? Oh, Scheiß drauf.
WTF? Eva, was ist passiert?
Eva? Das ergibt ja überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr hier drinnen jetzt. Ich hab immer gedacht,
dass die Leuchttürme sind. Das ganze System versinkt im Chaos. Milliarden von Leuchttürmen,
die fest sitzen am anderen Ende des Himmels. Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr jetzt.
Es wird ihnen helfen, den Zustand ihrer Partnerin zu verstehen. Lieber nicht, warum das? Das
kennen wir ja alles. Bloß dass es nicht so gewesen ist, wie es jetzt aussieht. WTF? Zumindest
Johnny geht es auch nicht sonderlich gut gerade. Hallo? Bleib hier. Ich bin Johnny und wie heißt
du? Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr. Das ist jetzt wie bei Matrix in Telefall.
Hallo? More voice. Oh Mann. Was hier ist Eva, du Trottel? Kein Scheiß, wir sind die einzigen
hier. Eva, was auch immer du gerade tust, hör auf damit. Wir wissen vielleicht nicht,
was Johnny will, aber wir wissen genau, was er nicht will. Und genau das beschwörst du
gerade herauf. Es ist bereits geschehen. Warum kommst du da nicht endlich raus? Da ist sie
ja. Blöver ist weg. Was hast du mit ihr gemacht? Entspann dich, sie geht nur woanders hin. Weiß
du, es ist eine Sache meinen Zugriff zu blockieren, um mich mit ein paar Oliven zu füttern. Aber
das hier ist jenseits von Gut und Böse, tut mir leid, aber das hier führt zu gar nichts,
wenn du weiter die Erinnerungen zurücksetzt. Aber jetzt ist der einzige Weg, du musst mir
vertrauen. Also bitte, beruhig dich einfach und warte hier. Dann los jetzt, auslösen.
Wo willst du denn noch hin? Es gibt noch eine allerletzte Sache, die ich erledigen muss.
Du kleine Poserin, es gibt doch gar keinen Grund, ein Tor zu visualisieren. Was soll
eigentlich dieses Melodrama, Nile? Warum kämpfst du so hart darum, dass ich, fuck jetzt hab
ich es übersprungen. Für das hier. Vergess es, wir haben keine Zeit. Nick, das wird schon
mann, dreh dich einfach um. Alles klar, alles klar. Ja, Johnny will sie ansprechen und
Riffa ist weg. Aber das Treffen zwischen Johnny und Riffa auf dem Jahrmarkt, das wurde
nicht gelöscht. Das erste, wo sie anscheinend anfangen, das ganze zu löschen, ist, als
Johnny Riffa in der Schule wieder getroffen hat und sich nicht mehr dran erinnern konnte,
dass er sie schon kennt. Sie ist weg. Sorry Kleiner. Jetzt gibt es kein Zurück mehr.
Das Game geht noch ungefähr 10-15 Minuten. Los jetzt, sonst sind alle guten Tische besetzt.
Die sind alle gleich gut, Mensch. Johnny, nein, Joey hat Recht. An denen in der Nähe
der Küche riecht es besser. Guck mal, sein Bruder lebt wieder. Zumindest, so wie er sich
das ganze einbildet. Ganz genau. Und man muss sich nur umdrehen, um einen Olivennachschlag
zu kriegen. Oliven. Ihn zu retten rechtfertigt gar nichts. Er kann sich immer eine neue River
suchen, nein. Aber sein Bruder gibt es nur einmal. Jetzt komm, wir stehen im Weg.
Und weg ist Riffa.
die das singt, ist die Sonnenblume aus Plants vs. Zombies. Und du, Johnny? Johnny
will Astronaut werden. Warum will Johnny Astronaut werden? Weil er jetzt früher schon gemerkt
hat, dass er Riffa sehen will. Ohne, dass es ihm so richtig klar ist.
Jetzt Outer Nick im Liegestürzen machen.
Oh man!
und da ist er bei der nase und will astronaut werden genau das wie es sein soll wie er sich das gewünscht hat
nur dass river weg ist auch wenn das jetzt wirklich so viel lieber ist habe ich so meine zweifel
er hat das also wirklich geschafft was du klingst überrascht was ist aus wir machen
jeden kunden glücklich denn wir sind einfach der wahnsinn geworden das hier ist kein erfolg
ach komm freu dich doch wir sind hier bei der nase wir haben nicht mehr viel zeit lasst uns
wenigstens ein bisschen umschauen viel gibt es ja nicht zum umschauen super ich meine jetzt
bekommt johnny zwar seinen wunsch erfüllt zum mond zu fliegen er wird aber nie wissen warum
was warum er es eigentlich will und river ist auch weg so kein haus keine leuchttürme
bitte warten sie hier das wird gleich jemand kommen dass sie herum wird wie armselig dieses
ganze theater nur wegen einem mädchen ich finde das ich finde das lustig wie sie die
rollen jetzt vertauscht haben vorher hat neil die ganze zeit so sprüche gemacht oder sie ich
wusste ich wusste dass du das jetzt sagen würdest wie armselig dieses ganze theater nur wegen eines
mädchens na endlich schön dass du wieder da bist ja ja to the moon die geschichte eines versagers
der astronaut werden wollte ein roman von joey wiles ich kann nicht glauben dass jemand sich
diesen schuld kaufen würde wir sind ja nicht in der wirklichen welt naja gibt es hier sonst noch
tja michael das die große frage ob das johnny nun so viel lieber ist weiß man nicht
vier mal mehr links wieso hat johnny noch mal sein gedächtnis verloren weil
er medikamente genommen hat als er jung war oder besser gesagt ihm wahrscheinlich seine
mutter die medikamente verabreicht hat nachdem sie ein bisschen durchgedreht ist weil sie ihr
eigenes kind überfahren hat was man auch von nachvollziehen kann und dann hat sie sich halt
gedacht die mutter von johnny hey dann lass uns mal johnny quasi um erziehen zu joy den sie
überfahren hat und hat joey hat johnny irgendwelche medikamente verabreicht dass er sich an nichts mehr
das an mir ist der aufzug in kleiner als außen also muss sagen die geschichte ist wirklich gut
durchdacht weil es gibt alles in am shuttle wird zur zeit mit hochdruck gearbeitet wir können uns
im moment nur von hier aus ansehen hier nichts was ist nicht hier das shuttle das kannst du
laut sagen weißt du was am eindrucksvollsten ist was denn das stück ganz oben und das untere
ende des shuttles da muss ich dir zustimmen und wie ich die armen seelen bemitleide die
diese details nicht ansehen können in der tate besonders die nase da oben ja wir sind nicht wenn
die arbeit abgeschlossen sind wird es wohl nicht mehr so wie jetzt aussehen jetzt ist die einzige
gelegenheit
der
sagt man was meinst du war die mondleitung im letzten jahrhundert wir fangen nicht damit an
fangen gar nicht das an wo waren wir hier
das ist die zentrifuge wenn sie glück haben werden sie eines tages lernen sie zu hassen
genau schleuderdings hier ist auch nichts wovon redest du effa kommt wir haben nicht
mal lange johnny gehts nicht gut ja hier o lp das also was du hier jetzt siehst das ist ja nur im
kopf von johnny das war ja in der wirklichkeit nicht so es hat sich an dem wie es wirklich war
ja nichts geändert johnny denkt einfach nur es ist so gelaufen und ob das jetzt besser ist mit
das müssen echt passiert ist das ist eine frage mit der sich das nachfolgerspiel feining paradise
intensiv beschäftigt quasi braucht man den ganzen scheiß hier überhaupt wenn ihr wollt
können wir irgendwann auch noch mal feining paradise spielen das ist nicht ganz so traurig
ich hoffe bei der echten nase haben sie größere aufzüge das ist das missionskontrollzentrum
journey stream journey das auf der ps3 das schreibe ich mir mal auf im moment passiert
hier nicht viel aber eines tages werden sie es in aktion erleben ich habe beinahe erwartet
dass zorn und auf dem bildschirm auftauchen das ist nicht gut gehen wir wieder nach unten
du musst wirklich mal an deiner kommunikationsfähigkeit arbeiten was willst du überhaupt lass uns gehen
jetzt dürfen wir hier rein
ich frage mich ob die echte nase wirklich so aussieht wahrscheinlich nicht das ist
ein konstrukt aus johnny's fantasie wiki facken vergleichs dann mit seiner hier mit
seinen hirngespensten trotzdem merkwürdig vögel zu hören aber keine zu sehen
sorry nahe ich dachte wirklich wir hätten eine gute chancen was
und hier ist der pause raum das ist david erst unser missionsspezialist freut mich sie
kennenzulernen zumindest hatte es in die nase geschafft so wie es aussieht meint
sie hat es bis zum ende durchgehalten selbst wenn es braucht mehr als das um astronaut
zu werden dann lass uns schnell den letzten memory link finden ich würde ungern das finale
verpassen was ist los ist es schon zu spät ich weiß nicht und hier ist unser anderer
neuzugang riva richtig schön sie dabei zu haben
hallo ich bin john das war aber knapp was zum teufel ewa du hast sie doch gelöscht
nein ich habe sie nicht gelöscht wie schon sagte ich habe sie nur verschoben was sie
mit ihrem leben anfängt ist ihre sache aber diese welt besteht aus öffentlichen daten
und johnny's fantasie und weil rivas persönliche daten nicht teil der öffentlichen quellen
sind kommt das hier alles von johnny trotzdem gab es nur eine gewisse chance wie konntest
du sicher sein dass es funktionieren würde ich war mir nicht sicher
das hätte ganz schön schief gehen können das ist dir klar oder du warst noch nie sehr
risikofreundlich nein einigen wir uns einfach darauf dass diese runde an mich geht wir haben
doch noch zwei helme oder ich glaube johnny wird sich über ein bisschen gesellschaft
land
Wie scheint, hat er es selbst geschrieben.
Ganz schön eintönig, wenn du mich fragst.
Wie heißt es?
To the moon.
Das ist ein schöner Titel.
Es ist ein schöner Titel, wenn du mich fragst, wie heißt es?
Ja, da seid ihr, ihr zwei solltet euch ausruhen, morgen ist der große Tag.
Morgen geht es zum Mond.
Ich will auch ausruhen und werden, eines Tages mein Sohn, wirst du das vielleicht?
Auf geht's!
Das gucke ich mir jetzt mit meinem Smartphone im Bett noch an.
Es gibt den Boston Uprising, San Francisco Shock.
Wie gingen eigentlich die anderen Games aus?
Die Overwatch League Games sind zum größten Teil übelst one sided.
Ich finde es schön, dass es euch gefallen hat, dass ja einstimmig die Meinung im Chat.
Ich muss zu sagen, ich hatte ein bisschen Schiss vor dem Game.
Vor allem wegen der letzten Stunde.
Weil das halt sehr mitreißend ist.
Aber es ist einfach geil, wie das dann alles zusammenpasst in dem Game.
Ich habe es in noch wenigen Games, sag mal mal, erlebt, dass es so einstimmig ist.
Ich habe es in noch wenigen Games, sag mal mal, erlebt, dass du den Abspann guckst.
Also sprich die Autosequenz und der Abspann.
Wenn du den geguckt hast, dass du dir einfach denkst, es ist alles gesagt, was gesagt werden musste.
Du brauchst nichts mehr.
Es passt alles zusammen, du musst der Sache nichts mehr hinzufügen.
Und ich meine, was hätte es für ein besseres Ende geben können, als Johnny und Riffa zusammen zum Mond Händchen halten.
Alles klar Leute, wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Und gucken, was wir morgen machen.
Bis dann, machts gut, tschüss, schlaft gut.
Tschüss, tschüss.